welcome welcome everybody it is your
favorite podcast ever made and you know
why it's your favorite it's because it's
the best right
hi what can you do it's November 11th
2022 it is Friday baby
joined by
the beautiful Ewa Prime nice to have you
thank you you did join us on on uh
surprise day yeah surprise joining us
nice kind of surreal I usually listen to
that episode right now you're in it
uh today's episode is sponsored by
Shopify which I'm very happy I love
Shopify I love it
Teddy fresh is on Shopify I love Shopify
yes well more on that later okay so
here's the deal
yes I underwent a hair transformation I
got the haircut the Jeff
what Jeff did to me is gone okay with
peace and love Jeff that that
abomination of God is gone it was
drawing on people though yeah I know it
was growing on me too I'm not gonna lie
when it started like filling in the
center yeah
how it grows you know the last episode
you had it on you were looking good I
know it was weird it's kind of [ __ ] up
I agree that's what's weird about it so
I'm gonna give you guys a little peek
but because first we want to run
actually you know what before we do that
we have a video of of the process so
we're gonna roll that but before we do
that just want to announce real quickly
Teddy fresh Black Friday sale is here
it's that annual CLS that time of year
get it while it's up because a lot of
thank you a lot of stuff is 70 50 to 70
off man yeah I know
it's crazy the owners have lost their
mind the owners have lost their minds
are every year this the color Block's 50
off all these Styles I think are 30
because it's like new Styles but like
the Looney Tunes hoodie this one is
super nice 70 off
yeah the older stuff on bigger sale or
stuff that has like just little bit left
with weird sizes you know yeah I mean
not weird but you know what I mean yeah
it's like you know there's like only
three Excel but check you can see that
this is all there's inventory but yeah
this isn't a markdown from 95 bucks to
28.50 okay yeah psycho yeah it's insane
from 80 to 32 from 95 to 38. that's the
snowball
this hoodie's sick Bro I also I'm
wearing stuff that are currently
available on the sale go work it this is
one of my favorite jackets I think when
it came out I don't know if for some
reason just didn't get enough highlight
enough attention yeah it's so nice it
was so good custom wait what's it called
if people can find it yeah it's on the
women's tablet I think it's like
browsing Fair oil
oh yeah like I'm just gonna keep
browsing
something yeah but just go you can just
browse and browse you're gonna find
something you like for sure
very nice
yeah oh here it is Fair Isle zip sweater
it was 145 because it's a really nice
piece but I get it's a little expensive
but I mean sweaters are wild like that
nice sweaters 43 bucks that's come on
guys that's a hundred dollars off those
are the pants I'm wearing right there
the purple
and women's plaid trousers from 100 to
30. wow I was so crazy these pants are
so nice I also want to encourage a lot
of people who kind of like like the
women stuff and are not necessarily sure
if they're like you know like a guy I
don't know or well you want to shout out
Ian's wearing women's jeans today right
so I think a lot of a lot of our fits
work unisex and you can try you know
sizing up a little women's plaid zip
jacket off from 130 to 39 bucks so you
know it's it's insane all this stuff is
like so high-end so nice
so that's it teddyfresh.com Black Friday
sale is going for like another week or
something I don't know or I guess I
don't know this stuff's gonna it's gonna
sell out so if you want to make a move
do it now and also just a reminder Elon
musker is selling out on or we're
stopping taking orders on Sunday
so if you want Elon Musk is a piece of
[ __ ] t-shirt get on it because Sunday's
the last day about I give to you hi okay
that's right that's it that's it thank
you thank you thank you oh there's one
other thing I want to address because I
saw this on the subreddit
someone from the yeah UK was like yo why
the [ __ ] is my
um 200 150 125 in in shipping
um yes it's the tariffs we don't have a
we don't have a way to disclose it yet
but it includes England's dude import
duties yeah and if your country has
input don't blame me don't blame us bro
it only costs 20 bucks to ship it to the
UK yes so our shipping fee is just 20.
so
yeah the rest doesn't go to us it's not
I think anything that we can determine
the same with Canada it's like right
there but they have import duties so if
you get if you're out of the United
States and you see crazy high shipping
costs that's that's talk to your
president okay don't you're barking up
the wrong [ __ ] tree but we do need to
disclose it so you people know why the
[ __ ] it's I know I think uh we're trying
to work on better like wording there so
it breaks down
yeah what is what it is actually but
currently we don't have that option
great that's it all right so uh thank
you thank you everybody and so let's
roll
I want to show you guys yeah blank King
Charles of the third that idiot just
took power in this and now it's a 130 to
ship [ __ ] I mean come on
Lizzy just she Lizzy just got buried in
the box and now yes
can't get over just how how [ __ ]
insane those guys are
Lizzie's in a box
[Applause]
um all right let's roll the
transformation and then I will reveal
all right I will reveal the hair to you
all so go ahead uh you have it in vmix
great uh we're here with Jackie AKA yeah
dab me up the realest the illness uh
made by Jackie Bieber and uh she is here
to beautify me and finally get rid of
this rat Nest I can't wait to shave it
to be crazy you presenting me with uh
some kind of sash here yeah you wanna
you deserve it you're number one
hairline and you have credentials to say
that right yeah you're a hair no this is
the best hairline I've ever seen for a
37 year old man yeah oh nice yes
oh pink oh pink here it's go time let's
go
[Music]
Friday baby
[Music]
my head is caked I can feel it oh that
already looks fire dude
let me get your lunch lady swag swag
yeah so how we posted this picture of
the prolapse and with the green screen
feature so his head was flowing there he
goes uh when my my friend Neil bent over
this happened we're toning this hair is
it like a Dye what is it what is it oh
my God it makes a lot oh my God that
felt like a lot
[Music]
we are washing the toner out yeah here
we go
ready
[Music]
yeah I'm just doing a mix of colors
right now I love that
for now I'm just uh painting some petals
I feel like Bob Ross yeah
[Music]
finger paint the pink on
[Music]
a wash
all right
[Music]
crazy that's crazy I have a gift for you
and I made it with all the love in my
heart wow and with my hands wow
talking bro and I got the hair I got the
size
thank you I love to the hair's so good
this is so nice best in the game here by
Jackie Bieber you know what it is
[Music]
all right so there it is
[Applause]
from
the worst to the best
there it is take a look you know you got
to kind of I love it yeah she's I think
it's the best haircut right now in the
whole world
I love she's so good I love what she's
doing and
um thank you Dan yeah there it is it
looks so good yeah I feel like a Game of
Thrones character I really do like in
Game of Thrones there's these guys that
dye their beards blue he actually was
one of the dudes that with that slammed
uh
uh Daenerys that dude had a blue beard
yeah Dario and the show he doesn't yeah
I know the show's [ __ ] but they're
right for not doing that because it
looks so stupid like that's you know
when anime adapts to live action oh you
gotta let certain things go or it will
ruin yeah you gotta let things go dude
your hair is like a playground it's
really been through the ringer
throughout this whole year yeah you've
set it on fire you've cut it that's true
yeah I think it looks super hot thank
you yeah and it passed the vibe check
with Theodore he loved it oh my God
Theodore kept saying it's so colorful I
love it and he's like
he's like every five minutes I still
love it
[Laughter]
so yeah his reaction to the Jeff haircut
was to cry
and ask me when we'll be back to normal
me too when I believe this is my hair he
wasn't a fan of it for some reason but
now he does like it he told me that he
changed his mind oh that's nice yeah
so a big shout out to Jackie Bieber a
friend of the show
she made uh she is like so good man
um made by Jackie Bieber on Tick Tock
and uh Instagram that's Dennis Rodman in
that first photo she did so you had two
hurricanes come here this week it's so
funny I know that's true they converged
um yeah but so check it out and actually
hit her up if you want your hair to look
like this
uh but yeah check her out we'll put the
link in the description but she's super
nice she's awesome she's a fupa Trooper
she's like a big uh fan of the show hey
gay been a long time buddy what's going
on it's been a long time
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] baby hey Gabe we didn't
get to call you during the Avi lobe
interview but will you tell me your
space question you had for him um
um
are we gonna live in Mars as a second
planet someday
I think based on what I was
understanding from aubi I think he
doesn't seem to be a Mars he is into the
interplanetary thing though I think he
is he was into it I don't think it's
probably not us yeah is the thing maybe
our great great grandchildren no not us
yeah like you mean us or human entity
you mean like while we're can you
clarify Gabe
[Laughter]
are we gonna make much like our second
planet someday you know yeah someday
someday in the far future yeah yeah I
think if I can guess what Avi would say
is if we don't kill ourselves
in the next hundred years then the
answer will be yes
[Applause]
Planet baby
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] would you go to marscape
would you go on an exploratory Mission a
one-way ticket to Mars
sure why not let's go
I don't know if they have white claws
there though
not yet I'm gonna make some problems I
need to go yeah hey Gabe happy um
Veterans Day happy Veterans Day yeah I
just stuck these steaks wow yeah baby
preparation for Thanksgiving
[ __ ] [ __ ] do you say
Thanksgiving
preparing already what you're preparing
for Thanksgiving what a quick thing
really Thanksgiving [ __ ] do you
like exercising your recipes you say
something like that you say
pre-thanksgiving free Thanksgiving okay
[ __ ] pre-thanksgiving
[ __ ] in my [ __ ] eyes and give me uh I
pink eye like Alfredo has
oh actually Alfredo's eyes been really
infected I'm pretty sure he has he gave
himself pink yeah
we got anti yeah we got antibacterial um
eye drops for him so so he's feeling
better
yeah all right guess what next Friday is
what
[Music]
looking for to seeing you next Friday
night as if it's my birthday
hey yo are you gonna get a lap dance
again
[Music]
I don't know it's supposed to be a
surprise well you already know about it
I think the guys are going maybe I'll
know about it
I gotta celebrate Gaby Gaby baby
it was a lot of fun last year I'm
definitely going I heard through the
grapevine the same stripper is gonna be
there is that true
something better oh
I don't know anything about this girl
and I'm not making assumptions about her
when I ask this just for the record but
like if she was paid to bring you into
the bedroom and uh finish the ACT if you
know what I mean would you be
participating in that would you be open
to that
sure
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh yeah
she's probably she probably doesn't do
that kind of thing but I just curious
what you'd say
all right well maybe we'll see you there
it'll be a fun time and we're gonna have
to celebrate this beautiful man uh Gabe
the white claw in the world the one and
only [ __ ] in my nostrils and pooping
it out of my ears [ __ ]
[ __ ]
how about this how about this snorting
[ __ ] and spitting it out of my mouth
[ __ ]
yeah starting [ __ ]
oh my God
you still managed to surprise game
hey do you think you think that would
cause a problem for your sinuses
probably yeah yeah I'll be smelling it
forever you probably need a Nutty pot
after that huh damn yeah
seems right yeah all right buddy happy
birthday that's super exciting we love
it and [ __ ] in my [ __ ] washing
machine and putting a load in it
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] puking in the drying
machine and burn it with my clothes
[ __ ]
all right buddy oh it's Friday
pizza places
[Applause]
you know
have you ever gone down on a girl Gabe
oh stop
have you ever you haven't is that
something you're looking to try
yeah someday yeah yeah okay that's good
what is your birthday coming up
it's like practicing how do you practice
do you ever practice on like the corner
of your elbow right here just being a
gentleman I guess
you're a good man Gabe you're gonna make
a girl really happy in front of the
mirror oh my God can you do it right now
pretend you're in front of the mirror
oh you have a lot to learn keep
practicing buddy there you go there you
go
oh you're ready to go Gabe you're gonna
make a girl very happy
oh
all right maybe maybe it's a good time
oh there you are anyway happy birthday
buddy we're gonna have a lot of fun on
your birthday okay it's gonna be awesome
all right love you dude stay good thank
you all right we'll see you next is it
next week
next Friday next Friday oh of course
it's on Friday what else would it be duh
all right I'm gonna bring like a
thousand white claws we gotta go to
Costco and get like a thousand white
clubs all right is that the best thing I
could bring like is that oh my God
would you just drink
yeah if you had any choice of alcohol in
the whole world would you yeah why okay
got it all right maybe I'll get a U-Haul
I should seriously get a U-Haul and just
fill it with white clothes be a fun
segment well I gave it some tequila
1942s
yeah let's stick okay all right now
we're complicating the order okay we
love you we'll see you next week okay
let's be good until then
all right have a good weekend
get [ __ ] under my fingernails [ __ ]
[ __ ] under my fingernails and then lick
my fingers [ __ ] oh how about this [ __ ]
on my fingers then eat buffalo wings
baby
laughs
all right we gotta we got we gotta get
out of this thank you Gabe love you
buddy nice to hear from you
thank you good there it is we learned a
lot he hasn't been down on a girl
but he would like to someday and I think
he'll make a girl very happy when he
does yeah he definitely will you think
he's such a sweet guy he'll figure [ __ ]
too and [ __ ] too he'll figure it out
yeah
oh yeah okay so anyway moving on thank
you Gabe
oh I forgot to show him cursed Gabe [ __ ]
well here I'll show you guys this showed
up on tick tock
and uh I wanted to see Gabe's reaction
to it but I can show him next week I'll
show you guys it's really good it's
Friday
Friday
I just want to remind you
foreign
[Music]
those videos are [ __ ] up I see them in
Tick Tock similar ones just ain't right
man what the frick
we got a couple memes to get to actually
uh first of all first of all Dan a lot
of people impressed myself included by
The Valor you showed on Wednesday yeah
your battle with the spicy chip you
overcame man thank you thank you so much
that was wild me when the video ends and
I have to go back to life
uh when you try to help your boss gets
banned for a week anyway
yep
I told you we are going to watch Dan eat
the Chip And then you can leave
this is fine everything's fine mood yeah
funny I love that Dan every time Ethan
makes in a Jew joke
we did get some great images out of this
whole spicy chicken yeah absolutely
debatable
maybe disagrees a boot you're oh how
about a boot a boot oh is that what you
guys
you did every day
it's not that bad baby did you get used
to it though it's like a familiar you
know what I had three sips of beer and
I'm okay now there it is that's all it
takes healthy good for you man
every time I see no show today yeah
I know that
the regular spicy chip yeah this is this
one you the last one oh my God
what the hell are we doing without men
true being down like this felt the same
as walking in on my dad crying
when you get so high you get scared
when's the last time you got so high you
got scared Dan
um
probably high school yeah yeah cool yeah
he's a professional now he knows what
he's doing yeah High School yeah I
remember once a yeah on a Fourth of July
in high school we uh we hotboxed a tent
with like 15 people and it got to a
level where like have you ever been so
high that your mind keeps like
forgetting what it was doing yes but it
was that was happening on like a five
second Loop yeah like every five seconds
it was like the reset button got hit the
cursed out that's exactly what it was
yeah but I felt like it was impossible
this was fragmented yes it was
impossible to get by like every second
yeah but that I mean that that was a
long time
yeah that sounds pretty bad man that was
me every time I smoked weed though men
only have two
so [ __ ] good so thank you Dan for all
the memories yeah yeah I was like
shocked that you just went on with the
show right afterwards I know man I
forgot you even ate it yeah
well I didn't like I said the other day
I didn't want to uh get two
braggadocious and then look like an
idiot but I I do enjoy spicy food if
you're so good at it then you need to
take me and Lena on
and the Christmas uh I'll think about it
you guys were asking me like trash bro
I'll put up a fat if there's a prize
involved I might have to do it yeah no
for them [ __ ] chairs
you can give it to charity if you want
I'm not gonna do it for you I'll put up
like a thousand bucks and anyone can
compete for it okay including me I'm
incentivized not to pay you I feel like
if you're all doing another round that I
gotta participate that'd be so much fun
I am so excited we're doing this you're
free not to but whoever wants a thousand
dollars I'm good the winner
gets it and we should say after 10
minutes or something then whoever makes
it that far splits it or something like
the lottery sure because after 10
minutes I think you're basically free
and good right yeah it would probably
start to fade yeah at that point anyways
so
yeah who would participate in that
it's still so recent I need to think
about it you guys were a thousand
I mean it was Dave would do it it was
horrible I mean the game do it
Gabe I would do the first time
oh yeah I love how that's good to do it
can we ship one to love oh yeah love
how'd you weasel out of this
I'm here no we've got a great rest of
Chip yeah please I want to throw me Sam
we gotta get to love a chip get this man
a chip dude get this man a chip Avery
the mod
oh God I don't know man because he was
so unfazed by that oh right
I think he destroy a chip it's such a
different Lane of challenge though right
like it's it there's overlap obviously I
don't be responsible if he like gets
like if we need to go to the ER or some
[ __ ] what about us now you guys are fine
you guys are on payroll I know you guys
have insurance
Avery Avery doesn't even get paid that
much to be dying on the job like you
guys get yeah he says he'd do it for a
thousand in the chat right now well
you'd have to go in to get the Thousand
buddy I'm not putting up thousand for
everybody
thank you for the five gifted Elon with
a shirt on
thank you for the good dude
um
did you see Ninja going off on me yes I
did we talked about it [ __ ] Judas I
said goodbye oh yeah I thought comedy
was alive and well
bro have you seen Twitter uh Ninja it is
it's the funniest Twitter has happened
exactly and I you know what I'm just
gonna say it I martyred myself so
Twitter could be what it is today yeah I
think
I was you were ahead of the time and
ninja doesn't appreciate what I'm doing
oh well tell me the comedy as well I
slit my wrist for comedy bro and Let it
bleed out for you to watch that's right
bleeding
the bleeding edge of Comedy that's so
true yeah that's so true so true
well said by the way how was your uh
[ __ ] after the chip uh it was it was
pretty bad I had a pretty rough like
really 20 minutes or so in the bathroom
yeah it was like it didn't upset my
stomach
um you know but then like later when it
was just naturally time to uh to do a BM
if you will
um yeah it was uh pretty spicy okay was
it just one encounter it was just one
just one and done done yeah dude not too
bad yeah all in all not that bad but
yeah it did it did suck for a good 15 20
minutes oh this guy thank you for the
gifted from one third Sam uh five gifted
and also CRC [ __ ] sorry I don't know if
it's a but they said I made the video of
Gabe that you showed so oh no way so
there it is love it I know Legend I
thought that was him yeah he makes a lot
of cool edits like that that's cool
yeah the spicy BM man those those really
hit hard like when it's bad boy your
whole body like yeah not good right not
a good feeling right but I got no
problem eating the chip again
I mean either let me put a little more
distance between me and the chip before
I come to a conclusion well originally
you were asking me like while I was
still actively in the throes of it and I
was like no [ __ ] way am I doing that
again now not a few days have passed
then maybe yeah maybe I mean I was here
when AB said he wouldn't do it for a
million dollars yeah I'm straight I
don't think it we shouldn't let a b like
he he got it to an extent that it was
like exactly like yeah
I think you'd rather be waterboarded
absolutely we can we can arrange yeah
you down yeah yeah Lena's being really
quiet I'm curious if Lena would do it
again oh I do it I I said that yeah
actually already said come on everyone
knows she would so if you wouldn't Dan
though then I probably reclaimed the
title I mean that's true that's true yes
she's right she's Technically she's
right I don't cable it's kind of
you can have it this is kind of my
attitude you know I'm not fair Lena I
don't feel uh away your opportunity it's
just not fair what he's doing to you
right now well I mean if she does it
again and she what did I get like seven
minutes or something if she gets more
then and she's got the title back that's
that's fine
that's true she's not gonna beat me
though you don't think so yeah well we
also have love now
love could be like a dark horse yeah do
you like spicy food
no but I have a pretty high pain
tolerance so I think that might come in
handy well next time next time you're
here in America we'll waterboard you as
well
I'm sure why not it's an American
special anyone else Zach and Sam
nobody's participating for a thousand
dollar account I mean Zach thousand's
not enough bro
I can handle space I'm more afraid of
like this stomach pain that I know I
will have so that's a no
it I don't know I'll think about it and
then Ian I'm absolutely out
he's not usually up for anything if
there's some some money on the table oh
my God that was my weakness I can't do
it yeah that was when Ian wasn't with
his head down life switching still right
right yeah that was wild all right man
you did it last time that's that's great
Olivia are you in or no or you said or
is this yeah I'm gonna think about it
wow I thought you'd all be in for it
that way he's muted she said she'll
think about it competition all right
well it's me only one person is gonna
get the money yeah well Ela too right
you said yeah you would do you do it and
I'm a maybe let me just dude it's gonna
be such a great segment I mean because
everybody did I just want to experience
it at this point yeah you got to you
gotta know it it's like when you become
a cop and they taser you everyone has to
get tasered it's like that yeah you
gotta earn my stripes burn exactly thank
you Claire for the 20 gifted Subs oh
let's go Claire absolutely
shut up ninja
[ __ ] dumbass I'm gonna make a fake
ninja account
I'm making a fake ninja account right
now verified real ninja
you can't anymore
like I'm suing Ethan
by the way Dan what are they gonna do
ban me no I'm saying they got rid of the
um it's in the story that's coming up
because we're going to talk about
Twitter but you can no longer buy the
check marks
I was actually they've already changed
their mind on that
yeah because yeah there's actually such
a good uh developments in the Twitter
world I love it oh my God I can't get
enough
it's so good he kind of in a roundabout
way was right about the whole bringing
comedies legal now because it is the
funniest the site's ever been not the
way he intended but no
and I mean there's now it's become like
the whole meta on Twitter is just to
make fake verified accounts yeah just
burn everybody to the ground last night
I was I was growing it was I'm not
exaggerating it was probably like 75 of
the posts on my feed were like fake
accounts trolling it's just it's
completely taken over one actually uh
this Eli Lilly
um is a big pharmaceutical company here
in America and somebody make a fake Eli
Lilly Twitter account
and said that they're making here I'll
show you guys
we are excited to announce insulin is
free now
and they make a new handle that looks
like totally legit and there's a lot of
people oh my God companies that don't
have a presence on Twitter which is
[ __ ] insane right so they'll just
make like you know yeah Eli Lilly and Co
this company did though right okay but
I'm saying there's yeah yeah so um and
then it got picked up in the news and
they actually lost oh my God
they lost like several billion dollars
yeah and now their lawyers are
threatening Twitter what do you think of
that and probably more that we don't
even know about
here look at this headline Eli Lilly
Dives after a fake Twitter account
promises free insulin
you don't mess with the Pharma companies
here yeah yeah
oops Yeah and then so there was another
article that says their lawyers are
um and talk now with with Twitter
so not good oops actually really really
bad I wonder if that could even be
considered to be some form of
I guess I don't know like it's some form
of defamation there is something there
right yeah because they're allowing
someone to
defraud them but I don't think so
because there's like section 230 which
means they're not responsible for what
people post although they are
responsible for the verified they're
verified though yeah
full sabotaging well clearly they got
scared enough that they turned it off
they just were like no more in America
yep
Derek runs thank you for the 20 gifted
thank you guys
correct yeah thank you to all the Super
Troopers gifting and all the members I'm
gonna be putting up a new
um see you next Tuesday podcast with
video and one audio track this time
[Laughter]
but we have a ton of these actually and
uh
um it's just so fun yeah
oh yeah you can say that yeah guys bad
news unfortunately no BTS this week uh
you guys were too bad so go [ __ ]
yourselves no I'm playing um yeah I just
didn't have enough this week so next
week
yeah maybe it was time look some weeks
are just not enough
um contact yeah I never thought it'd be
tested but the good news is I'm doing a
podcast every week he'll probably be
doing a BTS now every other weekend I'm
taking the load off a b a little bit
with my pod appreciate that yeah I've
been walking around the office trying to
provoke fights and [ __ ] yeah I got you
man yeah we don't need that he's not
kidding I'm not kidding
any time there's a little argument
between like anyone I'm just walking
back they're like what are you guys
saying she's like hold on hold on what
are you doing he almost broke me you
know what's the way to do it it's like
the housewives approach basically if
something is happening then you like if
Dan and cam is having a little something
then you go to Dan and you record then I
mean a talking head camera about it
right yes we need like a little
interview let alone talk about it and
then the next week they watch each other
see what they said about it right then
it becomes like drama for the whole year
there you go baby back up back or weekly
yeah let's make the two content what do
they call that on Big Brother
professional yeah we got to do that yeah
they're confessional confessional oh
that's such a good idea Dan and I would
never fight yeah by the way an absurd
example by the way this is Dan watching
other people talk about him in the uh
humble that's the new sound bites
Mission okay yeah
um you know what I love is that while
all this like actually funny stuff
happening on Twitter
um Elon
posted that really dumb meme about the
um
the thing what is it yeah it's hard to
keep up not sure so many yeah so much
dumb [ __ ] I mean here I'll just go to
his Twitter account yeah go to his
Twitter account and the thing is he's
posting through the pain you can't even
find his account when you type Elon Musk
there's so look at this no that's not
him oh my God where is he that's not him
I can't even find him get this I follow
him and he's not my first result he's
like my second where is he
here we go to people it's so funny
okay here he is
[Music]
yeah
um
he's been posting through the pains so
and like doing crying laughing emojis
about how he wasted 44 billion dollars
basically
but let's see
um mainstream media will still Thrive
but increase competition from citizens
will cause them to be more accurate as
their uh
oligopoly on information is dispute are
you [ __ ] serious bro I literally just
saw Mario flipping me off from a
verified Nintendo account
yeah what is he trying to like justify
what's happening yes also Elon Musk is
not an oligarch let's let's make that
very clear if exactly
let's see uh as Twitter pursues the goal
of elevating citizen journalism
didn't you just lose Eli Lilly like five
billion dollars
media Elite will try everything to stop
that from happening does he really think
that or is he just pandering to like
conservative
it's hard to say I he's kind of high on
his own Supply I think
I think he really is surrounded by what
is this it's like a fence that just
won't point out how badly he's [ __ ]
up
Twitter HQ is great this is a real pick
game over
okay
he says hit all-time high of active user
[ __ ] you know
he's probably not lying about that yeah
that's fine because everybody's coming
to see the [ __ ] show right now exactly
some especially funny tweets what about
the one that I did that you banned me
for you [ __ ] [ __ ] quite the day
[ __ ]
um before we go too much further into
the Twitter stuff we are at break time
oh it's making me log in I'm not logged
in yeah I logged you out after the other
day we got scared
[Music]
all right so uh sorry to interrupt we
got to go to a break yes thank you Zach
so anyway we have a whole Twitter thing
that we're gonna do next and also so the
main segment we're doing today is Olivia
is going to teach us at long last a
great request
how we're all gonna do makeup you're
gonna do a tutorial we're going to do it
on ourselves
I wonder
making me fine and just have someone
send it
first
um I wonder if we should do the makeup
first so that we can do the whole
episode in makeup
uh we could do it uh coming out of the
break if you like yeah maybe we should
do that and then we'll talk about
Twitter and all that other stuff okay uh
Abigail thank you for the gifted
and some so that's the way that I was
trying to show it's like sorry I
couldn't resist if you guys go down
yeah it's just like almost worried in
one just wanna Moya donating a kidney to
a relative next week please don't get in
trouble I'm gonna be bored don't worry
about you you should log into like
burner accounts here so that we can okay
tweets and stuff yeah that's a good idea
this is the one ELO was talking about
though sorry I couldn't resist I didn't
get this that's like a resistor yes
exactly I do know that because people in
the comments were like what is this so
what the [ __ ] does it mean it's an
electrical engineering joke it's a blown
yeah it's the most old man joke wait I
still don't get it oh I couldn't resist
stupid ass the resistor yeah
stupid stupid ass it's just a this is
the bad it's a word yeah
no layers it's just one joke it's oh
this is also called the resistor oh
that's funny yeah bro you got work to do
dog
crypto work all right all right all
right let's thank our sponsor and then
we'll do the makeup and then we got a
whole bunch of fun stuff to talk about
including all the Twitter uh our
favorite tweets and stuff so let me
thank our
special sponsor I love
[Music]
Shopify we cannot do Teddy fresh without
Shopify it is an e-commerce platform
they do the processing they basically uh
host the website
they have templates to make website
building easy and they have all these
tools on the back end for
it's it's it's like the One Stop Shop
for hosting and e-commerce website and
it is so [ __ ] good
can I explain a little bit from myself
please please yeah
um we've been on Shopify from the
beginning day one always been so
reliable because as you guys know we
deal with a lot of crap online like you
know because we're YouTube
um creators there's a lot of people that
would just want to mess with us or try
to get the website down or whatever
nothing ever happened because Shopify is
so like robust they just they really got
their [ __ ] together
um I don't know if I can say that on
that you can say that you already did
there are they're so well put together
and it's always been super intuitive
anything we need to do on the website
um if there's any enhancement that we
need there's all kinds of apps that you
can install that add features onto your
store yeah so you can really do it as
simple as you need or as like complex
that's the thing that's so good it's
been good for our business from like the
most rudimentary basic business all the
way up to like an e-commerce giant they
cover you the whole way and it's like
seamless I mean this really is something
because we started this website from
zero yeah and now we have you know like
30 I don't know 35 employees and um it's
covered as the whole way there's really
big
um huge Commerce websites that are on on
Shopify yeah so I've always been so
happy that we chose them from the
beginning because they've been like just
amazing to work with yeah they are it's
a good company I'm really happy
Shopify makes it simple to sell to
anyone anywhere whether you're selling
it's funny to read the event the copy
now it's like we just we just gave you
the most
sparkling adore endorsement but okay I
gotta read it
whether you're selling a vintage tea or
recipe for ghee start selling with
shopifying join the platform simplifying
Commerce for millions of your favorite
businesses worldwide with Shopify you'll
create online store in your Vibe
discover new customers and grow the
following that keeps them coming back
Shopify was all the sales channels
sorted so your business keeps growing
from an in-person POS system to an
all-in-one Commerce platform even across
social media platforms like Tick Tock
Facebook and Instagram and thanks to 24
7 support and free libraries full of
educational content shopify's got you
every step of the way
yeah love you you've built multiple
websites with Shopify yes sir it's
insanely easy and you can like it's
almost like one click setup or you can
like if you want to specify things you
can sit for hours and like build the
perfect website for you it's like both
sides they have a great like Health
Community super good documentation it's
like insanely easy and everything just
boom works you kind of if you're looking
to start an e-commerce website you're
kind of been saying not to also in the
beginning when we were starting out I
didn't really know like any connections
or who to use for what and so I
personally really liked it's not part of
the read but just from my personal
experience
um when I was looking up Shopify I could
also look up Shopify experts and that's
how I was able to find like web
developers right that are yeah you know
they are specialized specialized yeah
and so it kind of helped me figure out
like finding a person to build a website
for me because I don't know who to go to
um dude building a website from scratch
to do e-commerce would be insanely
[ __ ] stupid like yeah holy [ __ ]
um it's how every minute new sellers
around the world make their first sale
with Shopify and you will too
um
yeah when you're ready to launch your
thing into the spotlight do it with
Shopify the Commerce platform backing
millions of business down the street and
around the globe
check this out go on try Shopify for
free
and start selling anywhere sign up for a
free trial at shopify.com after dark all
lower case go to shopify.com after dark
to start selling
online today with a free trial awesome
shopify.com after dark thank you so much
Shopify you uh thank you I love you
yes
get after it
okay let's go
all right I need to pee again I don't
know what it is I have that uh fiber
like I slam a whole cup of fiber in the
morning I think it's this drink too but
it's like I I can't stop peeing it's the
gamer Subs but I just started drinking
it
it's so good you don't notice you just
keep drinking and then you just go to
the bathroom yeah
I'll be right back I'm just gonna run
I'll be right back okay all right how
bad you have to pee right now
[Laughter]
you got something for everything Zach I
see Olivia getting ready
I'm seeing a ton of fupa Troopers in the
chat and even some of the members
messages saying they love Shopify oh a
lot of people
uh my name is Jeff says my wife
stationary company he's a Shopify
and they're a web developer and I love
using Shopify that's awesome ow yeah I'm
so happy that they're a sponsor because
I just I love their product so I can
really give them a legit yeah
um endorsement
there's such a like Staple in e-commerce
too so they integrate with most things
and it's so easy to just get into it
wherever you're sewing
Olivia
is this makeup gonna be able to cover
the cut I have on my forehead hundo P
baby for sure
cool so what is our plan for the makeup
stuff should we talk about it yeah so I
am going to be sitting here
and simultaneously going around and
helping you guys
um I have my stuff here so I'll show you
what to do tell you what to do it would
take me a million years if I had to do
all of my makeup
um so whenever you guys need help
[Music]
so do we do it on ourselves yeah and
I'll tell you exactly what to do when to
do yeah we are going to follow along and
I'll show you
we got all of our brushes and stuff I
don't know what any of this uh well I
mean I can Intuit what a lot of it does
but so we're just gonna look at the
mirror give it 30 minutes you'll know
what every brush does
God knows I need it
I actually do need it today do we have
another mirror
no uh there's another one yeah we have
another there is
foreign
let me break it real quick
[Music]
cool
don't talk to you sorry we're good we're
getting all this stuff ready makeup
[Applause]
by the way
I think we should change the title too
oh no oh God
Ethan's big announcement
Ethan's final Ethan's transformation
okay well hold on we didn't ball Parker
yet Dan you're gonna put a halfback
title out there from there
you gotta let it stew a little bit
you know what I mean change is coming
whoa no kidding love what the [ __ ] is
that oh my God
but even with that filter no I don't
know what you're talking about
[Music]
it's just me people are saying don't
change it it's because
um the views are low
they're always kind of lower on Friday
on the live I think it's just Friday
people are just out and about today's a
national holiday too I don't know yeah
change it to Dan eats the chip again
changed my life
all right let's just do the let's just
do the makeup then all right so um
people have been requesting a tutorial
from Olivia it's true yeah we got lots
of comment that her makeup is always on
point Thank you always and and you you
not to toot your own horn but you do
admit that you have some skill in the in
the makeup Department I can do a little
bit just a little bit I am gonna say
don't yell at me if I do anything wrong
I'm not a makeup artist
um I'm talking to you okay
um so what we have here is basically we
all everyone here has their own makeup
kit yeah yeah right yes indeed we have
we got the mirror we have all the the
tools I've been listening to it I'm not
much of a product girl like I don't have
specific brands that I go to but I have
specific items that are included in my
in my get ready with me thank you for
the gifted prolapse penguin appreciate
that so um you Olivia is going to take
us step by step we're all going to go
together and we're going to apply our
own makeup and then see how it turns out
so so where do we begin first thing I
would like all of you to grab is your
foundation it's the this the bottle
that looks like this it has liquid it's
not exactly the same these it's the one
on the left this one it says fit me are
we sharing okay Fit Me Foundation this
is normal to oily I would like for you
to put a few dots on your face if you
think that you need a little extra
coverage in a specific Place put a
little bit extra just use my finger yes
and then use one of the big brushes to
blend it out all over your face try
doing like a dog is that a good dot on
your nose yeah an adult on the other
side
and then one on your forehead
okay
like that okay go I'm in all right
I got this and then take one of the big
brushes yeah one of these and blend it
out blend it out girl blend it out blend
it blend it girl
blend blend never what is it you can
never it goes blend whatever
I've been watching blend don't blend in
that's what he says no
yeah it used to be an Instagram uh but
okay blend don't blend in whatever the
[ __ ] okay he certainly doesn't blend in
all right okay so I've got my foundation
on
how's everybody over there doing
everyone looking good over there
Foundation wise Zach looking good I'm
hearing crickets I was just looking for
some makeup if you feel like you need a
little bit more you can add more
coverage yeah you can do layers I don't
know what listen
I don't got nice skin like
like yodu I got [ __ ] up I got pores
the size of the Mariana Trench over here
my skin is seeing
it's been through a lot I would say
okay here this this dabbing is not
enough
um
of your hand most people put it on the
back of their hands that's why I always
have color on my hands so smart that's
fancy
totally makes sense
okay a dab bro come on I mean you could
do a dab you could do a glob right here
we go here we go a glob Global I'm gonna
do a glob
what is foundation
what is foundation Foundation is
supposed to even out your base it's
supposed to give you
Flawless complexion
and a lot of foundation
do you go under eyes sometimes you you
can if you want to close your eye if you
have like veins that you want to cover
on your eye you could go over your
eyelid but we're going to be doing
eyeshadow yeah I got that which Middle
Eastern dark eyes
which is the one I see like when women
at the end of the day oh my God
they look like a mine
[Laughter]
um I wanted to say what's the one I've
seen at women at the end of the day they
take it off and it peels off like a
freaking their eyelashes no like off
their whole face
makeup are you talking about like those
weird viral tick tocks uh maybe maybe
I'm thinking of something else yeah I
don't know if you don't immediately know
what it is okay so I think we're all got
our foundation right we're ready
everyone Blended I guess
let me see I don't look like Ethan but
yeah I mean I have okay beautiful I'm
going for the gold I know what you guys
are trying to do I would like for all of
you to pick up your concealer it's a
little Lube with the same very similar
color to your foundation
tube that one yeah and I want you to put
a dab
here
so you guys all watching you guys are
missing the instructions bro okay all
right we're picking your [ __ ] cell
phones away if you guys don't pay
attention we're not distracted no
screens we're trying to figure out I'll
do it with you guys I'll just put it on
top okay I want you to put is this the
one right here a DOT here yeah yeah Kim
okay a DOT where your bags start so like
here and then a little bit going up on
the side
three swipes
that's how I wipe my ass
um
listen oh my god
wow dude what at least you can tell I'm
wearing product damn yeah but you know
what I need two am I doing the swabs
okay so do you see where the dots under
my eyes are I do yes there
and the tear duct right where the bag is
and then going up
okay this is fun you guys get to do this
every day yeah I love doing it you do
like therapeutic do you do that every
single day but
yeah I really love it is do you feel
that putting makeup on your face is bad
for your skin or good for your skin or
neutral certainly bad really yeah see
that's tough that's a tough one it is
tough I don't like fudging with my if I
have a lot of makeup and taking it off
makes me concerned because it's like you
really feel like you're irritating the
skin yeah oh that sucks wow people do
that all the time
and so what is this this is um concealer
so what's the difference between
concealer and and what was the one we
just did Foundation concealer Bridge
it's it's stronger it's stronger that's
not three dots so it's like nine well in
my own way I'm walking my own path I'm a
mgtow baby I'm wearing which brush this
one
um yeah a smaller brush blend that out
oh [ __ ] yeah a smaller than your
foundation brush all right so we're
blending it in under the eye right under
the eye right yep all the way right
under the eye and then on the side swipe
it up swipe it up
okay so I'm blending up okay I like what
I'm seeing the blending up yeah it works
right look at that oh
you look good girl so how high do I go
under my eye it's kind of hard so go as
close as possible you don't want any
blank space there you don't want it
um you also don't want to hurt yourself
yes I do that's a fine line what brush
do you use for the concealer
um any smaller brush smaller like
not this small right not that no
like this one would be good or this one
and and thank you do you ever get makeup
in your eye yeah all the time does that
does that really hurt
um no no not a big deal I can touch my
eye super easy I think because of so I
have a concealer question for you yep
um I always have like really dark hair
under my eyes but then when I try to put
concealer on I feel like it just makes
me look worse like it exaggerates the
problem interesting maybe try hey dude
what the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
I'm like all out like I'm transforming
today okay yes but sometimes when I
watch makeup videos that is what they do
it's like a lot okay and at the end they
look gorgeous okay so it's okay that it
looks really heavy because mine looks
kind of yes transformation but the
makeup ones that I've seen like on Tick
Tock where they're like insane
Transformations they put a lot of
problems but is this supposed to blend
like yes all the way out okay so let me
blend it out let me blend and blend it
out the reason why your concealer is
supposed to be a little lighter than
your foundation shade is because you're
highlighting parts of your face and then
we'll go in with Contour as well oh of
course of course so where the light is
supposed to hit your face which is like
the center of your face the high points
that's where the light colors go
dark points of your face where your
cheekbone sinks in your jawline yeah
that's where the shadow goes yes they're
saying I need color corrector you can
use color corrector so under your eyes
it's like you put the opposite of the
color the opposite of purple on the
color wheel is orange so I put orange
here so you could I'm not a huge fan of
color correction some people swear by it
so don't take it my word is gospel
because whenever I try to put concealer
on yeah it doesn't make it look better
it kind of like makes it worse okay
because I think I have like darker color
so what's color correction so it's like
using Orange it's the way it works is
like if you have purple undertones under
your eye the way you cancel it out is by
orange being the opposite of purple on
the color wheel it neutralizes it makes
like a grayish yeah or I have no I'll
try it yeah
okay they make like orange concealers
and color correctors let me see y'all
let me see the makeup let me see switch
between Dan is looking nice wow
let me see look up
um
maybe are you doing anything yeah oh yes
get right on the on the camera look at
the camera
okay maybe I'm just too beautiful I
don't know that must be the problem
that's what she's doing I love a little
too much a little too much maybe blend
out a little bit did you blend did you
blend love and then wait the blending oh
man look at the Gorge uh yeah
Ian you're not doing it are you guys I'm
switching you got out of this one yeah I
know you would do that what about is Sam
participating or not
she's she's a sister she's kind of
assisting because none of us know what
any of this is the teacher all right
she's running around helping I think I
read the Zuckerberg I'm done with makeup
for a bit all right yeah that did back
for her and I think we're ready for the
next part all right I want you guys to
take out this
this powder powder okay we have a loose
face powder are we doing lines
so what you're going to do is open it
yeah we got it okay we've opened now
what is this this is powder so it's made
your face is wet wait wait this you just
take this off wait what did I do wrong
oh no did you break it baby powder it
does yeah I think you're what do you do
you can do that so you're supposed to
what am I supposed to do you're supposed
to leave that on right yes but it's okay
need more powder than that
because you don't want too much do you I
mean it's all preference so I peeled off
the little sticker and I see that
there's like the little holes here so
what you're going to do is you're going
to tap a little out into the cap ah I
see okay so you have some yeah the
powder is here to dry all of the oil
that you have smearing I love powder
it's just baby powder right it's the con
it's like yeah I'm sure that it has baby
powder okay so we're powdering where we
put makeup or the whole face where you
put makeup which is the whole thing
is saying that I left my pimple out I
can't cover it it's the only thing I
need covered and it's not covered you
want help let me see yeah hell yeah I do
you left chat is saying that or did you
read one comment that said that
one okay I
well not when you're trying to do a show
what about when they're a member yeah
you read one person said it
you make it sound like all the chat is
hyper focused on your pimple I
think that's beautiful me too
it makes it look like silky smooth my
powder just exploded everywhere dude oh
dude I can't control my powder that
powder oh my gosh
it's all gone I got powder oh my God
where'd it go it's gone it's gone how do
you do that
see that's crazy
burn her do it I dare you all right see
what happens I feel like if I ever try
to do that I just make the pimple look
more visible that's because you are
blending you're blending in you're
blending wrong I keep looking over the
chat and everyone's just like kept like
LOL Dan laughing my ass off yeah what am
I doing wrong you look fat you look so
good well you know there's a lot of
difference I think that's why okay let's
play yeah make sure to get the Dome
though I've seen people who don't like
hair and they stop right here and it
looks wild no I have like a dog I've
come so far also the concealer looks so
good on you yeah okay so rocking the
concealer do magic to add more coverage
is like put it on the back here that's
so true sometimes if you tap it out for
a minute it adds concealer no just to
the coverage because it'll start to dry
a little bit so that's Foundation this
is concealer okay let's get Glam so look
up this Dot
no this okay it's like a dark stain
I got powder in my eye
I think I used Too Much powder but I was
trying to tell you yes
you can blend it oh you know what get
the air blower pick this brush live this
closed take this brush and just wipe it
all over your face hold on we have a
better idea Amy's grabbing that you know
where it is baby
yeah one at a time there's too many
people talking okay Amy's grabbing the
air blower okay and now now so what
explain what's going on over here in
Ila's corner I'm just adding a little
bit more
I have a dark stain right here on my
skin so we're buffing that out yeah
trying to see if she can make it
disappear
does that make sister sense does that
make sense tell me how you feel about
that
my lips and mouth yeah you like yeah
yeah is that Fab
all right thank you
[Music]
get closer baby you're gonna get right
here closer like right right in frame
yeah
oh my God
is that part of your makeup routine
I do that everything in the morning
it did a little bit I've been waiting a
year waiting a year to use this screen
again yeah we've spent a lot of money on
this [ __ ]
here do it in frame come stand in front
of the camera so they can see or stand
like yeah come just come in for it yeah
so get lift it up
go all the way plastic
oh my God
oh I can't breathe when it's on
it's like
you literally can't breathe you're like
suffocating oh
so the air in the world and not a drop
to breathe so question for Olivia here I
put the foundation on higher oh yeah but
should I do the concealer is just for
around the eyes right I don't you don't
need any extra okay so just a dome and
what about the powder powder if you feel
like you're oily up there you can uh oh
what any of that means I'm just gonna do
it oh sorry babe uh Rory
Rory Hicks thank you for the gifted
that's so generous he says all five
million of them all people in my hive
have gathered around our one computer
with their makeup kits that's nice the
Rory is our resident uh mole person
yes well for you specifically I'd like
you to blend out just right here I need
to blend by your eyes with this yeah
just because it's created creases wow
yeah
yeah yeah just right there okay that is
also why I feel like whenever I put
makeup I end up like trying to
immediately take it off because I feel
like if I have makeup it just makes like
creases more reasonable sometimes uh if
you powder right after application it'll
make it not crease as quickly
but or like a setting spray that
sometimes can help
you beautiful airbrushed right I look
kind of good I mean yeah obviously I
like that when you can't see the details
in my face that's great that's ideal it
looks like you should be in Twilight oh
for sure I'd be a hell of a good vampire
all right okay next I want all of you to
pick up your butter bronzer okay Queen
butter bronzer it smells so good does it
taste I might be allergic to the powder
no it's making me sneeze here's the
butter bronzer now what is the butter
bronzer it makes you look
comes with a lot of makeup comes with
applicators that don't work yeah
okay so don't worry about that yeah
don't worry so this goes on my whole
face why does this look like the skin on
my balls
applicator
looks like a scrub he's doing that maybe
stop it totally does didn't they didn't
they apply that in a different way what
do you mean it's the famous ball sack
pattern
I'm just calling it like I see it mg
so whole face I'm never gonna unsee that
so I want you to take a fluffy big ass
one like you do just any of the bigger
any of the big ones do I need to like
remove the Schmutz that's been on it you
can just tap it off a tiny bit you don't
have to so
tap it into your butter bronzer a little
bit don't get too much you're getting
too much you're getting too much okay
okay is there something on this surf oh
yeah I guess there is oh it does smell
good so places that bronzer goes where
the sun would hit so forehead high
points at the forehead
exactly that's how I feel when I try to
watch makeup tutorials they're like you
know just where the Sun hits and they
have like an exact like okay yeah and
I'm like everywhere people everywhere
it's called the three method so here
here
you'll be doing a three okay that's
where bronzer okay good good the three
that twice
so under your chin like this on the
jawline
where your cheekbone line is
coming out wait can you see this
[Laughter]
you can definitely see it
a milk
all right what was that shitty movie
with John Travolta where he's like an
angel and he's all white oh
milk you would know
are you talking about powder oh is this
name powder
I think you're where he has like magic
powers or whatever yeah that's called
powder but an idiot stupid ass title
yeah it was John Travolta Greece it's
not grease like this it doesn't go how
high does it go on my cheek so you have
where your beard line is yeah just there
where it cuts your cheek off no no don't
go in all the way oh okay don't blend in
circles uh how else do you blend
like for on the cheekbone you don't want
it necessarily to be
all over this real estate you want it to
be linear on the cheekbones I don't need
you I'm going all the way through here
you want to step halfway
we will
Olivia I better look like you when this
is over I think you will Dan is I think
gonna come out looking the most yeah I
think you're right Zach's gonna look
like the Joker
he's putting on green paint
all I know it was just a mess on my face
you know how to blend that in so I
always clean up Zach does anybody not
notice yeah
sister they're bronzer I don't yeah I
don't notice them let me help yeah it
doesn't I didn't feel like it did much
sometimes maybe it's supposed to be
subtle when it starts when you start the
makeup you have to sometimes like scrape
a little bit with the brush oh you gotta
scrape it I just didn't have enough on
the brush yeah here we go now we're
getting somewhere I just scraped a
little bit more oh embarrassing oh okay
there we go it's dead
yeah look at this like a cheat code
yeah zoom in on this oh my God I'm just
breeding powder here
oh my God that's too much
don't get it all over the laptop too
everyone deserves to look beautiful even
louder
it's just powder or whatever no it's not
it's fine a little bit of air
but it's not I don't see it otherwise
it's like a [ __ ] thing I don't want
the sun to hit me
I gotta [ __ ] prepare for all
possibilities
beautiful thank you
all right all right I'm bronze I'm
bronze the [ __ ] up let's check in on
everyone yeah let's see I don't look
like Olivia I will tell you that yeah
we're far from that oh my God though as
might come together kind of yeah yours
is coming in there wait hold on I think
that's one more whenever girls do their
makeup in their videos it's like a lot
it looks kind of starts like how you
look in the beginning and then wait wait
I look kind of slay right now yeah yeah
you do yeah you look slang
okay let me come on you look good
yeah no your skin looks nice and even
and I think it looks beautiful yeah it
looks really good let's check in uh
switch between everyone Dan looks yeah
Dan's about to drop a nuke over Japan
he's still laying so hard
what's the connection you're just
killing people you're slaying okay
Jesus sorry
too soon I mean it's been like 100 years
almost
um let's switch it anyways Zach um
you're not really trying I get the
feeling it was trying
I'm not really trying no it's not what's
wrong with it he tried just as hard as
he did with his mannequin head
I don't know because every time they cut
you it's like
like
I mean I kind of have to do another job
too is the bronzer on that's fair that's
a really good point did you did you get
to the bronzer I think yeah okay oh my
God you're right Ethan you gotta do my
makeup
just use like 10 times more than you
think you need right that's basically my
strategy so far AV to face the camera
please I see those cheekbones that looks
nice yeah and no pimples
dude it actually healed it's yes just
who yeah [ __ ] Elena are you following I
am I mean it doesn't look beautiful
beautiful Gorge yeah if you look at the
same as shoes Elon did just right it
doesn't show up like it does when you
see in videos I think I think it's ours
look if you want to add more we're not
using a product I'm watching maybe maybe
don't be shy you gotta cake it on okay
Jim says blend don't blend in I say cake
it on and cake and eat the cake when
you're done yeah cake it on and eat the
cake
perfect I'm certainly a makeup Channel
and then Sam are you doing it or Cam I
don't know Cam's doing it let's see cam
you look good
and it's very very white it's white yeah
turn to the other side Kim to the other
side there I did that side oh yeah that
side is popping you know cam is on our
old camera so um he's being done a
little dirty by the Yeah quality super
super bright maybe maybe yeah you're
looking a little blown up yeah why don't
you come over here Kim
that would be like the weirdest Twist of
my life
Shane Dawson
oh my God yeah young boys that's what
they do
channels and mine Crafters have in
common they like to [ __ ] kids
then are we okay
what is going on next up just saying
true nose Contour
okay take a smaller brush like a little
eye shadow brush yeah like that
dip it into your bronzer wait we're back
on the binder we're still in the bronzer
okay this is only if you want
so you're gonna take the bronzer I want
you to start by putting a little
line across your neck a cute little hit
on the nose I feel like a little hit it
lifts your nose up wait did get a shot
of this hand I'm scared to do this one
get a close-up let me show you why mine
looks good you ready you'll see right
here
[Music]
I'm just that's it that's right okay
you're too shy so after that line
because I try to look natural you know
take the bronzer on either side of the
bridge of your nose to like straighten
it out essentially okay
it's not showing up super
but I guess here let me let me try
harder
yeah now I see it now okay
we're getting somewhere
trying to blend it in this Pat is this
supposed to like be an explosion of
powder every time I brush
smaller all right bronzer
so what's the tech did I do it I think I
did it wait
show me one more time the technique so I
want you to
put a little line across a little bit
above the tip of your nose like
horizontally yeah okay
yo you guys need to get on my [ __ ]
level I'm tired of you guys keeping me
down
okay okay step out that step one
okay and then straight lines on either
side of the bridge of your nose
show me please Ian I just I'm actually
infatuated with myself I just want to
see myself
damn look at good dude Ethan makeup Guru
beauty stuff channel
is that the Apple Klein I heard so much
yeah
all right next next please are you ready
yeah I want you to look up
which is the little pink Square
huh
now you need to be careful this one this
is a dark blush I like it because it's
really Vivid but you have to use a tiny
tiny bit I think when I was born there
was too much blush on my rosacea face
that could have been it yeah
it's beautiful Zach that's a trend
what rosacea essentially people do on
the blush Trend people love Rosie Rosie
Rosie Drew Queen oh so I'm getting a
fatty brush you can yeah fatty brush and
then where do I apply it so dip it in
your blush yeah dip it in the blood and
I would like you to Pat it off after you
after you dip it first okay okay and now
I want you to put it
like hug the brush kind of at the top of
your cheekbone that's you just dab it
yeah I just go like this right here
just a dabble do you
okay I see that oh that's powerful
that's beautiful
I need I need blush there actually
because
my cheeks are doing something there that
they need a little help it makes you
look like a cute little like doll now do
I just dab it up or now I blend it in
you can yeah yeah I feel like really
good too okay let me see let me see
right
now you look good I mean yours looks
like Pretty Natural if you could pee
baby you can always add more if you if
you would like let me see on camera
again
oh what the hell Jack
Zach's off the rails wait you're using
the wrong bride he's going Joker he's
going joking oh no it is becoming Joker
makeup isn't it Zach I want you to use a
big brush to blend that out when you're
ready okay a big fluffy brush yeah okay
then it looks great okay yeah it looks
great how'd I do mine is it your makeup
looks also looks great it does yeah
sense
[Laughter]
is this better Olivia
yes it looks like you're breaking out in
the hives when I do it I probably am
doing an allergic reaction it's double
red on my face
all right beautiful
now I want you to grab the highlighter
which is this one
okay
the shiny stuff
this is wet and wild when Reckless
powder let's get Glam so the places
where oh it's closed oh it is closed
so hold on we gotta unseal these every
time I got a reset here with all the
powder from Nathan dude I need to wear
makeup every day I can't go back to
looking like normal me I don't want to
see my face how I feel you know I I've
had this routine for maybe like two
years or something I just like I like
the way that I do my makeup I think it
makes me feel cute
um you feel more confident yes and then
when I like decide to change it up I get
so freaked out because I'm like I'm used
to this right what am I gonna do you
look so different so I look so different
I just this is what I do
without makeup I don't know probably
I'll show you I'll say hey I'm doing my
skin that's so nice look I don't have
any pores I don't even look fat
I wish the skin that I will figure out
my makeup which camera is I have no idea
what I'm doing I think you look really
pretty let me see you do you like it
right now you look great are you kidding
me yeah you're glowing just wait until
you put the Highlight on I'm gonna take
this back with me do it all right so
what size brush do you use for the open
up the highlight and I want you to take
the fan brush the fan brush
Fanfare I never knew what it's for what
is it the fan brush so the way that it
works I have one
foreign how much do you want on there
with the highlighter like
okay I want you to swipe it swipe it
so I got um and then put it right there
this is funny uh fellow Mew plague 31
said Zach Lewis live from the capitol
January 6th whatever the interaction
maybe let's go
okay sorry Olivia no you're good
two-year anniversary concert yeah all
right so get the shiny stuff on the fan
brush
and I want you to put it right at the
top of your cheekbone so like right on
top of the blush it just goes on top of
the blush
okay here we go and it just okay
no it's sparkly yeah that's what it does
it just makes me shine yeah did you kiss
my shine on yeah yeah all right don't
put it yeah don't bring it so far in to
your nose just keep it on the outer whoa
you bro yeah that looks like a not good
one to inhale it's got like glitter in
it
does it have asbestos in it
God I hope not
there may be a small Trace amount of
asbestos I mean
don't want your face Lighting on fire do
you no I want yeah no not at all
actually
okay just lay all right does everyone
feel slay
yeah next I want to take a little bit of
the highlighter on your ring finger
yeah okay and I want you to just put the
bright color in the tear duct oh for
real
not inside your eye so just touch it
with your fingers
or below the tears just right here
so like on my nose but not my [ __ ]
eye not your nose on the corner of your
eye oh my God this seems dangerous yeah
it's definitely not just be precise you
know
it opens up your eyes it does and you
just do a dab yeah dab it's a dabble do
you and then
place I want you to take it on your ring
finger
you don't work it in you just dab it
yeah
it has to look like a cute little Dot
I need to work mine in a little bit
okay
I think I got that uh
sometimes it's hard to tell you see let
me see
yeah you guys look good
[Laughter]
a little bit more blush more blush yeah
okay because I think it'll make the hair
look good yes more blush
whatever you say we dab it off first
crinkling period I did and on your hand
oh I hated that
oh I hated that James Charles you're a
[ __ ] loser this shit's easy
oh no I'm coming for you I would like a
channel called not James Charles
okay I think I need to blend it in a
little bit now
there it is
just like that
next Friday I'm gonna do this exact
thing
and you guys will see okay
if I learn my homework oh
cute oh
James Charles crying watching right now
okay
okay
so
can they not hear me
no they can hear you your hair keeps
rubbing yeah thank you there we go okay
so eye shadow time you all have an
eyeshadow palette scary somebody said I
look like the Pillsbury Doughboy can you
ban them I just said that in time
I got him thank you yeah just
permanently banned them yeah yeah of
course sister sniped them
they didn't put parody in parenthesis
yeah exactly next
you need to put joke and parentheses so
I know you're joking otherwise I take it
personally and your band yeah yeah yo
look all of these colors what do we do
with all this you guys get to choose
your colors I'm gonna give you an
outline and you guys get to choose pink
how does this work
so
I want you to take a dark color
I'd use like one of the like one of
these I use let me grab a brush like
this
a fluffy brush Okay small but fluffy I
want you to take a darker color that I
want you to swipe it
here in your oh yeah that's your crease
a darker not not the color that I want
not the color no this is your transition
shade so it's your blending shade so
like a dark brown like a like a darker
brown
darker orange so this is between the
eyeball and the eyebrow yes you'll feel
it when you blend it out you'll feel
like you're eyeball guiding you and my
eyeball away from one of
them I'm so focused right Sam suggested
I do black and go for a goth look I like
that
[Music]
do some corpse bait full black metal
so where where do I put it it looks like
I punched in the eye yeah
crease above my eyes
I looked like
okay okay wait hold on Queen
how high up is this supposed to go yeah
okay this goes the line where your
eyeball ends okay I see I see I put mine
where your eyeball in the crease of your
eye it exaggerates the shadow so I feel
like I put way too much on it but do I
want to exaggerate because I already
have the shadow there
yes all the instructions
makeup says that that's a pretty place
to have a shadow okay I don't ask
questions
I just do what she says times 20. how do
you do this without it's kind of a Vibe
you kind of have to do it with your eyes
closed right um Dan if you want to blend
that out you can take another fluffy
brush with no eyeshadow on it and just
like blend it out okay
show me show me show me
beautiful
all right I want to see everyone now
you just laugh like the Pillsbury
Doughboy oh [ __ ] band Zach
hmm
dude you look good Amy but look at the
camera look at the camera face on
okay I like what I'm seeing
thank you do I look slow yet come on
yeah yeah I'm seeing it
I'm seeing it I want to see Elena I feel
like we go through the same uh dance in
the lab oh that looks good though yeah
okay
what do you do orange
yeah I did uh I did two colors like a
dark orange and like a dark purple
pretty
oh [ __ ] I think I [ __ ] up
flew too close to the Sun there
what happens if you want if you [ __ ] up
your makeup and you want to like you can
take concealer you can take your kids
yeah control Z clean it up a few
concealer
just to start over
yeah
this is all right
I'm actually fine I think it's okay now
I want you to take your favorite dark
dark shade and I want you to put it with
a smaller brush like maybe a brush like
this
and I want you to put it just right in
the crease on the outer whoa
so I want to do like a hot pink at some
point so this is this could be here or
it could be it no this is your hot pink
okay yo how small is it supposed to be
um okay like I missed that
just had just right I feel like I'm
doing a terrible job on this step it's
like concentrate it in the outer corner
and then take a bigger brush and blend
it out see this one is it supposed to be
this like High feel like I went way too
high on this eye no that's that's right
that's right well then so I'm too low on
this one
yeah okay
somewhere some people are born with it
some are Dan I don't know what to tell
you I know I've never said I was
you know maybe it's Maybelline here I
can help them
don't squint okay
Jesus let me see myself squint what
exactly Zach is out of control
maybe okay okay did I do something wrong
no
no you could never do anything wrong
Zach look like a [ __ ] Smurf
see look I I think I messed up with that
last step that one was a little scary
yeah
that one was big size too so
yeah eyeshadow kind of scary
but I'm taking the challenge
I want to be more hot pink
do is there any okay I think so is there
straight guys that go out like this like
I'm sure sure of course of course really
no I'm sorry I just I'm just I'm
honestly curious I know yeah I know
there's all kinds of
ranges of people you know I know yeah
really one of the Dolan twins had acne
and he posted a video about it and he uh
talked about how he used concealer good
for him and if there's not there's about
to be because dude I'm about to go I'm
about to go clubbing with the boys to
take a fluffy brush
with the boy I was a step behind I
apologize because I was struggling wait
after the first layer of the eyeshadow
what do you do for the second layer let
me see Dan oh yeah so you get a darker
color and you probably go Darker Than
Black oh so yeah just try to hear me put
more black okay got it got it I had that
problem
if you want it and then you you just go
higher with it just a little darker in
the corner here and then and then brush
it in okay like right here I see
and then brush it yeah
okay
you guys like the blue black
I do
classic
it is the classic blue black okay great
like a bruise you look like a bruise
yeah
all right are we ready
um Sam Smith someone said I'm giving Sam
Smith oh yeah right totally do you see
that yeah
this is a new me man for real ball Ethan
is dead this is the rock star
face
[Music]
you need nail polish oh absolutely so
boring look at my boring old stupid
hands I'm gonna come off and maybe
consider wearing a skirt like a good
quilt
and I'll sit I won't wear underwear and
I'll sit with my legs crossed I'm sorry
a kilt with those slides would go pretty
crazy
oversized t-shirt and then kill it yeah
all right what's next all right I want
you to take a little like domed
eyeshadow brush maybe like that
like this
there's some [ __ ] okay kind of
rounded around the top and take the
darker color you chose yeah and I want
you to go under your lash line with it
focusing more on the outer of it okay so
like right under these eyelashes got it
where the root of your eyelashes the
hole under the eye all the way
no stop about three quarters okay okay
and put it right at the the base of your
lower lashes yeah
oh my God
it's silent why do people that this is a
delicate operation here no this one is
really how do you apply makeup if you
need glasses to see
you know right I don't know
maybe contacts let me see and
bro
concealer you can use concealer
it's a Vibe though kind of a Vibe oh is
that too heavy because mine is about
that heavy as well I went way too heavy
yeah but it's black it's very
unforgiving
you just gotta own it that's what I'm
doing I'm just gonna I'm just gonna own
it
yeah
oh no let me see you Elo Elo looks like
okay okay okay
yes the black I think I [ __ ] up with
the black
had more black
more so it looks intentional
I'm in
do we ever apply a lighter color of what
we wanted to yes okay yeah just checking
what do you think Olivia Zack
exactly
wrong
ah you're good you're good you're good
it's a it's a Vibe it's the rose show
isn't it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right can I see me because I think
yeah this this is not good I thought I
was looking so good and now it's just
all wrong you look golf dude yeah you
like it you look like you're playing can
I go wrong it just needs to be cleaned
up a little I think you can clean it up
yeah
I'm seeing the chat say blend Dan okay I
will blend then and don't blend in
though yeah you can never okay too much
cake and then eat the cake let's go
bathroom break
okay I'm just I'm owning it Olivia
mm-hmm
I'm going rogue a little bit that's okay
you can't just let it slide please
that's what makeup's all about going
rogue yeah
love that
love that
love it love it
all right let me see oh [ __ ] now I look
like a [ __ ] costume do you want to
help cleaning it up yeah clean me up bro
what happened I can't go out like this
what happened it looks so good you were
nailing it
oh God
all right we have to do some surgery
here don't worry she gonna fix me up
okay what did you eat everyone's saying
Ethan no concealer
her foundation I might just use this one
this bigger one yeah yeah
all right Carol's just back up can you
do it look up
just your eyes
your latest man handled me
you need a wipe or something it's too
strong and it's black
you know we need we gotta hit the makeup
wipes
are these makeup wipes
okay thank you thank you Sam
we have emergency makeup wipes
so Olivia it looks like I have black
eyes right now is this gonna be fixed or
did I mess up
um
I think you look pretty look can you
look at the camera Maybe
you could take your uh powder brush and
just clean up under your eyes a little
bit your little Powder Puff but I think
that it looks pretty I turned into Uncle
Fester again yeah I don't know what you
did the makeup with the himbo merch is a
nice match yes it is goes well that
affects me
can you fix me
please I want to be pretty again
what you did is devastating is it that
bad
just a lot of black powder
okay you're helping though keep going
yeah you do you'll be pretty again thank
you please
I'm not saying you look good baby have
you seen that oh thank you guys
appreciate it
no to the other side of the face give me
keep talking and maybe I'll get a BTS
this week
just kidding I'm desperate that air okay
yo hi sister what's up guys how you
doing at home you guys should follow
along all right you get makeup and
thanks you can add uh idiots
just clean it here
do I look better again guys
I do big news if you flip the mirror
it's actually much closer yeah dude is
that just really big you didn't tell us
that big news
whoa whoa yeah this is like the cheat
code to make it oh that is so much
easier yeah okay wait so so this is the
makeup remover
I'm gonna
I'm gonna try to fix myself
because I want to be beautiful
I don't know what's the cheat code
there's one you flip it it's like the
mega mirror you turn around the mirror
we didn't the guys didn't know about
that is that for all these mirrors you
flip it you get a yeah a close-up yo is
this a magic mirror how do you get so
close to your face it's like magic
mirror bro
who invented this Einstein
some genius so what do you think how do
I make my
professional you could add concealer to
cut the eyeshadow and make it cleaner
I tried that Zach you any plans tonight
dinner you know
uh yeah yeah
going to the boxing gym after this oh my
God
oh my God I walked in what never mind I
walked in once with a uh like a french
vanilla okay my coach asked me if I have
a [ __ ] really
that's hardcore man
[Laughter]
get your ass walking with a french
vanilla he's like you're not cut out for
the sport
I'll just tell you right now with that
yeah vanilla [ __ ] too
mistake I mean I guess it's a little
better I don't know
is it better yeah yeah much better okay
okay I'm just gonna leave I don't want
to [ __ ] it up anymore
I can't I genuinely can't tell if mine's
[ __ ] up or not you look good you look
like you're in Green Day yeah I'm liking
it I'm liking it somebody in the chat
suggested I blend it with some dark
brown so I just did that and it seems so
shout out to whoever said that in the
chat
okay let's move on let me get me out of
here next
pick your light color and put it all
over your lid what's a light color
whatever color you want I like wait we
use our finger yes
oh with fingers I use my finger for this
with my finger just because it's easier
to pack on wait where do I put it put it
on the lid oh the lid and then if you
want to add a shimmer in the inner
corner like here on the lid that is
extra special I do want a shimmer so the
light color we do with the finger so you
got black where what what light color
would I use with black or since I'm
doing a white or a cream so I should
still do that even though I'm doing yeah
really dark it'll lighten it up like
look how magical I look right now or
like a metallic if there's one that you
like that's a good time to use it okay
I'm back baby
[ __ ] you uh listen I can't be hanging
out with you just do this right on like
the right on the lid of your eye so like
right above your eyelashes basically yes
okay and underneath the dark color that
you okay here we go
I feel like this thing
and if you want your eyes to pop a
little more you should add the Highlight
on your lid
if you just take a little and put it in
the center of your lid it makes it extra
special we always want to be
we do I do
I think stunning I want uh can you add a
little Shimmer on your lid this one a
little bit okay
you can put yourself to my lid yeah okay
let's Shimmer it up
shimmy
oh yeah let's Shimmer yes yes yeah that
made it look a little bit less like a
five-year-old that's really pretty
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes we love it
oh
lay down
this is so exciting exactly are you
early learning a lot are you I am so do
you watch makeup videos every year no
but sometimes I try to just to get like
some understanding of the basics yeah I
think you would learn a lot from I did
maybe like watch five videos in my life
okay yeah because I should I just don't
have time I
it's like
the time is so limited I gotta choose do
I watch makeup or do I watch Bachelor
Housewives yeah Housewives yeah
I just started Housewives which one the
Salt Lake Salt Lake your genius that's
the best one you guys we just watched it
last night yeah dude it is [ __ ] so
good yes that's the best one also
Bachelor in Paradise this season is like
off the chain are we doing the Kiki
right now
we're having a cookie
I don't know I think I know what a Kiki
is we're doing makeup and Kiki yeah
makeup and Kiki
I don't think I like
okay whatever I'll just leave it I'm not
gonna [ __ ] with it anymore you could get
rid of the bottom if you don't like it
I'm leaving it okay that's a good amount
what's next next I would like for you to
take the liquid eyeliner you don't
really look like a musician right now
okay I like even Stardust yeah
the liquid eyeliner oh Jesus now we're
all gonna [ __ ] it up a liquid eyeliner
okay that sounds dangerous yeah I don't
even attempt this kind of stuff so what
you're gonna do what does that one look
like
it's like a black marker it's basically
it's one black marker a Sharpie it's a
little Sharpie for your eyeballs got it
you're gonna try your best
to keep it as close to the roots of your
top lashes as possible so a very thin
line and you go from the bottom of the
laugh
I go I start like more towards the
middle and then I'll do the corners what
if your hand is shaky I'm gonna pick
yeah I'm gonna poke my hand and my eyes
out with my shaky ass hands so I'm a
little worried about this one okay you
know what we could do instead grab an
angled brush a little small angled brush
is this this thing
right here no that's mascara oh I mean I
wanted to quit
grab a brush like this like a little
angled brush and then there's black
eyeshadow in that palette right
throughout the butt [ __ ] here
like we need black [ __ ] on the [ __ ]
edge of my eyelash
like what well I don't think we have an
angle how do you think is that important
like this yeah okay so do you have a
black eye shadow in that palette oh
um yeah because if the liquid is too
hard you can always use this with a dark
eyeshadow and then it's much easier yeah
no no don't turn it to the side turn it
to the side yeah look at that oh okay
that but like uh you want to go this way
wait so now what are we sorry I missed I
just found my thing what do we do with
it okay yeah if you think that using
this tool will be too hard pick up an
angled brush and black eyeshadow and
then line your top lashes if you think
you can use this the thinnest line
possible on top of your top eyelashes
all right I'm down for a challenge let's
go I know I kind of want to go for the
challenge I don't want to be a loser
yeah don't you know you're not a loser
uh across the top of the whole eyelash
yes okay how do you know how far so
we'll do that we'll hit the wing after
let me see and you start from all the
way from inside
I start when I'm doing it I start from
the middle just because it's easiest and
then I'll slowly work my way
I think I did it I mean I made a couple
of little mistakes but oh you did yeah
you actually did do it
I'm making a YouTube channel
oh yes someone just said stabilize your
elbow on the desk oh
too late for that but yeah
let's check in on everyone let's see
Zach will know what's happening Zach I'm
trying to find an eyeliner
you need one yeah I can throw mine too
oh there's an extra in there yeah this
for Zach ready ma'am
that was a great throw you didn't even
try to catch it
what do you do if the line is not
perfect Eli did such a good job
no it's not perfect though yes it is
what are you talking about stay up close
let me check in on everyone here let's
see Dan slang it's really hard this
one's really hard
I think I've almost got it oh Lena's
right on right on yeah I think it's so
far we're gonna start doing this more
often beautiful I'm feeling like my um
experience painting a Warhammer
Miniatures is helping me out a lot right
now
okay let's check in whoa AB is
he's hiding his face like Phantom of the
Opera
don't look at me CAM looks awesome
sleigh thank you
loving it working it better and then
feeling it you know that looks so good
but what do you do with the little with
what little bits of black now you could
take I don't have one but you could take
a Q-tip lick it and like take it off
yeah or a makeup one I have one oh but
it's fine it's really fun for the
purpose of what we're doing that slang
yeah literally
literally
Pearl Harbor
okay thank you people yeah someone said
this isn't how you get are going to get
alpha males in here Ethan I know I'm
kind of leaning the other way now I'm
just trying to
all right now it's time for the wing get
the
we're going to take a small angled brush
and black eyeshadow
angled bra so a brush like this
angled brush
oh this tiny little [ __ ] yeah little
blah blah
now what am I doing you're gonna take
some black eyeshadow
and you're gonna
continue the line of your lower lashes
like as if the lower lashes continued
going up you're going to take with the
black eyeshadow and you're going to just
continue that line just do one little
line
oh I love this part well it's all black
you're not even gonna see it well yours
is I'll try though
I'll try to make it extra
dark
so you're talking about like a corner
yeah
mine goes wait this one's angled did you
like damn this is where I lost it this
is where I lost the plot right here let
me see
so what I do doesn't look that bad you
barely have any there I know but I
notice it
oh [ __ ] continue it
and yeah I don't think that mine's gonna
show because mine's all black
how you feeling there Zack ab's not even
facing the camera I feel good and you I
accidentally go but when you fill it in
you look good dude thanks Dan like the
truck you look really good you look
really what I mean okay yeah I like that
slaying on tick tock
so embarrassing let's see this is you
sorry
all right
so everyone is really serious getting
into it now it's just crickets
everyone's super
Dennis when you're doing all this [ __ ]
around your eye you don't want to like
stab yourself how's it going over there
AB it's real quick it's quiet over there
less
stuff kind of messed me up I don't think
so don't look that bad
it kind of looks like a rock star look
sort of
okay I'll continue continue
um I'm good ready yeah I'm ready yeah I
guess so there's something called brow
gel that's sitting there I don't brow
gel that was really sometimes I'll fill
it in with do I want to eye shadow so
you would fill it in with like an angled
brush which one's Brown
this no the the white tube is the brow
gel okay white tube of
and that's to thicken your eyebrow no it
sets your eyebrows in place it's gel so
if you're don't use that yet if you're
gonna fill it in though you do that
after you want to fill it in with a
pencil or something first what your
eyebrows oh
just use the gel yeah this one's the jar
yeah I want to fill it in I want to have
it you do it so I want to have those
duck or that uh Pull It in first and
then the gel I want that Steve Harvey
look oh I see so where's that then
pencil yeah I'm filling it how do I feel
it you can grab a small eyeshadow brush
and then a dark brown in your eyeshadow
palette oh okay okay
is this a nice one we got what is this
one no no it's very how much was this
it was like eight dollars okay and this
probably lasted the longest time huh
yeah do you think it matters like if
it's cheap or not because
I personally
don't some a lot of people do I mean
obviously some makeup products that are
more expensive are better but some of
the best stuff is just at CVS how come
what makes better product better
ingredients I think the taste well but
like what about well I know but like
does it look better that's the whole
point right
yeah and the color might be more Vivid
liquid cheese
okay
but it doesn't sound like for everyday
use you would need
something super high end like that no
that's very interesting I see that oh
yeah she was like perfectly angled
in your mirror
okay I'm filling again I'm giving Steve
Harvey okay Dan with the wing
somebody in the chat suggested it was
too heavy on the bottom of my eyes and
it was making it look droopy and to just
add a little concealer
droopy
blur and just keep going with the with
the up the curb of them okay that's what
I'm doing now
that is just
I love what you're doing
all right
oh my God Ethan not good let me see
that's [ __ ] God that looks pretty
good Ethan you like that yeah [ __ ] it
dude I got the thickest eyebrows in the
game
hell yeah
eyebrow King eyebrow King yep all my
hairlines are Godly
uh
[Music]
I have strong oh embarrassing strong
eyebrows are everything
aren't they I was a step behind what was
the eyebrow stuff do I even need it I
got thick ass eyebrows yeah right I
think they're pretty I think it looks
good okay I think you should do it it's
really fun see no you oh you're saying I
should do it yeah look at mine and Ethan
if you want to clean up your brows you
can put concealer on the back of your
hand and with a smaller beautiful kind
of brush es you could just sealer you
concealer yeah okay just add a straight
line right underneath your eyebrow so
that there's like a line of light in
between your eyeshadow and your eyebrow
underneath oh there's problems
everywhere
like here yeah
this is called carving out your brows oh
really I should probably do that I'm
gonna carve this [ __ ] out I gotta carve
myself carve it like a turkey
wrong and then looking like a mom you
know what I mean there's like Trends and
then you can like literally like that
you are a mother makeup that's true you
are a mom you define what it looks like
yeah you're literally a mom girl you
know I'm a mom
so maybe that's not a good way to
describe what I'm thinking you literally
have given birth twice all right
literally
that's true
um I feel like that did not help I guess
I don't want to look like a boomer does
that make sense sure
because there's like Trends to make up
I don't want to do I don't understand
this one is not coming
but that's okay we love it anyway trying
to clean up the mistakes here
all right
all right I'm gelled up in the Brows I'm
ready to go we good all right
take eyelash time
ready fake eyelash time yeah
I normally get eyelash extensions so I
don't wear strips every single day
um it's just easier
right now or like eyelashes I'm wearing
strips right now those are like crazy I
don't necessarily wear those oh my God
why because they're so big yeah here
Michelle
but we thought it would be really fun to
get crazy lashes okay I'll be around to
help everyone with these yeah I will
definitely need help with this so I want
everybody to take off their first lash
how long do we could stay on wait what
does that mean
it's just for the day you could rip it
away
oh yeah okay way to glue and you cannot
yeah there's lash glue wait what already
somebody said wrong product no no no the
eyebrows the adhesive to the packaging
eyebrows the Lash glue the little white
product
all right is everyone following along on
the eyelash
no the other one with the gold top other
wait hold on we have some stamps this is
the Lash glue oh do you guys need lashes
I have a bunch here
okay thank you
where's the Lash glue this okay so what
do I do so you're gonna take your
eyelash and on the band just cover the
whole thing with a like line of glue the
bottom when you band what is the band
will take off uh you have your eyelash
yeah
the Lash band
this part there's a band on it or the no
no don't take it it's already feeling it
already feels sticky is it not like free
yeah oh I'm putting it on this yeah okay
yeah yeah there's a little adhesive on
it Dan yeah but I think it's just so you
should add more yeah they stuck it to
the package um is it gonna when I take
it off is it gonna ripe off my eyelashes
no you apply it above your eyelashes I
did these when we were doing Frenemies
they're really easy to rip up okay yeah
okay so this just goes on like like you
have to wait about like a minute for the
glue to get tacky or else it'll just
slide everywhere okay okay and then it
just pops right on there huh yeah once
once it gets sticky
and you like you can manipulate it with
your fingers and stuff
I recommend middle first
hit it in the middle hit it in the
middle first
if you hold your mirror like this too
it's a lot easier you can see
all right here we go
let us
damn this is gonna be hard yeah yeah
this one is not this is serious is this
the hardest one make sure the glue is
tacky before you try
[Music]
it's so unintuitive to put this on
how do you see your
s I'm looking in the mirror
okay okay I'm just going for it
oh whoa I didn't commit yet
Zach
then um
that interference that's that's that's
RF hits that's not her hair on the uh oh
okay yeah uh you might want to go move
where the receiver is or something I
need to leave it down oh I did a good
job you did do a good job so wait do I
need to keep it on your finger and pinch
the fake eyelash with your real eyelash
just to like melt it like this
yeah
you guys I think I did a really good job
oh my God look at me
dude I killed that bro
it's so light you you think that it
would give a little more weight on your
eyelash but it doesn't wait wait just
feel free
yeah but is it yeah people are saying
audio Yeah it's what I just said
Hitler's saying what yeah is there an
audio problem uh it should be we should
be good now what was it
there's an issue with the lab okay
that is like this
[Music]
yo this [ __ ] Wild
okay it's like there's a little baby
it's like a little much
yeah exactly that's how I feel it's like
there's a little animal here on my eye
to me this is the real me I don't know
what you guys are talking about
furry creature let me see maybe
something much
these aren't even that big I feel like I
could go bigger okay okay we'll go
bigger you look Zach can you play okay
Ethan the Jeff okay Ethan okay
you're looking at the news okay Ethan
this is a step too far I can't do this
man you've come so far bro I just like
I've tried like ten times before you
just got to commit you know what I mean
but this is Hardcore makeup just so you
guys know just go for it on eyelashes
just admit Dan just commit is that
so you'll be able to say that you've
done that
it's like commit in my I can feel it
like oh you did it you got it is that it
yeah you did it it looks good it's awful
this is a horrible feeling it is
horrible weird I feel like it's in my
eyeball I don't know how people walk
around why do people do this to
themselves this is awful it definitely
feels like I've got
a little hitchhiker on my eyes yeah a
little critter I'm not gonna make you
guys do this because this is super
important
but every day
I put black on the inside of my eye oh
we're doing that we're doing it I go
like this I take an angled brush at this
point
and I go right in this water line yeah
I'm doing that
if you're putting paint in my eyeball
today I feel like my eyelashes are
meeting my eyebrows right now this
this is the worst thing ever why do you
why do people do this to themselves
anything to look good bro can I move it
if I put it too far yeah
so everything to look good wait
ing
to look oh God
all right let me start over with that
one there guys
now my eyes all sticky
oh [ __ ] does it feel wrong
I mean it's fine they both feel just
crazy so what you can do is take your
mascara black tube we're almost done
how much glue do you use with the how
much glue not a lot just a little bit I
feel like I can't even open my eyes
because there's so much I don't want the
bottom and now I'm really [ __ ] up like
my actual eyelashes are glued to my skin
bruh bro this feels this is the weirdest
sensation ever having [ __ ] on your
eyelids is awful
leave it leave it though it's like not
even you have to leave it the whole show
it's not even though pictures kind of
like like so we can post closer up you
know
for sure
we can post it to Twitter so people can
get a room look at it yeah all right
here I go I'm going in for the top one
now right I wonder why I felt so weird I
was putting on the bottom that was so
funny
this is so much harder than the first
time
and uh
okay I'm in
I'm lashed up oh
butterfly kiss
foreign
okay take your black tube of mascara
mascara like as if this wasn't enough
I want to look at everybody we're gonna
put mascara cam you look incredibly
interested
I'll be honest bro
chromosome somewhere in there
I think you glued your eyeball the wrong
way dude wait look at the camera again
what does it look like he's looking to
the side yeah that's what I'm saying
glue on his eyeball
all right next let's see who else we got
your wife dude
Jack is actually
you got him on there oh my God
they're on there that looks like a cheap
prostitute after a long time
I look like an expensive present dude
after a long night you look good at me
Lena's out there like 9 11. Lena did it
what like oh my God that was about what
I meant you
[Laughter]
erase it from your memory
it's for the record I heard I just
because for the
try to explain it no I think okay I have
to explain it oh my God something
glitched out when you hit that
what's happening Zach you need to kick
stuff I'm on it someone keeps hitting a
button someone stop hitting the button
the mics are muted there you go okay I'm
back yeah who keeps hitting listen I
kept saying uh uh world tragedies okay
so let's not you know it'll have an
accident yeah let's just say you look
more like the um
you look more like Chernobyl I don't
know can you say like oral maybe like
this when you say I mean wanders maybe
instead of treasure you're giving
grandkids girl people died mass murder
slaying okay it doesn't work you look
like uh oh see that one doesn't work
either okay mascara keep my mouth shut
do I look like the Pentagon okay
the Pentagon on 9 11.
we're starting to lose them then be sure
all right all right all right take this
and just keep those things to you in two
weeks guys yeah no it's not no it's not
like that come on if we do I'm going
home
think of me now yeah or not because yeah
I was like
blend your regular eyelashes oh into
them with the mascara is that what that
is oh good this one is that this thing
it's the tube Essence lash oh I'm A Lash
princess right now wait what's next uh
what's next mascara which I'm using oh
I'm not scaring my fake eyes yes
and then I also really like putting
mascara on my bottom eyelashes
verb to get mine
where do you guys think I went wrong
that I mean I'm the eyebrows definitely
a huge mistake
up until the eyebrow you look good I was
so I'm so disappointed because I was I
was ready to [ __ ] myself dude the first
time you can if you want
I was about to do a stranger where you
sit on one hand till it's numb and it
feels like okay oh it's a stranger yeah
of course
there you go thank you
uh would you mind wearing a mask with my
face on it I'll put a mirror yeah just a
mirror on my face yeah
thank you
you're always down for
The Adventurous stuff I appreciate that
okay I'm working it I'm working it
all right I'm working then how long does
this take you in the morning Olivia when
you're not teaching not this long I I
hope not I will normally
wake up I'll wake up
an hour before I'm supposed to leave the
house it takes you an hour or no just
everything will take really because I
already wake up an hour before and I
don't do the main couple she's good at
it though she's fast practice you're not
doing any you're doing everything right
okay
um the makeup bit itself how long does
it take you don't stay from beginning to
end yeah between it depends how much I
care I could go for like three hours and
I would still be doing it let's say
you're just going to work to work normal
work day not like on camera like just to
work 30 25 okay
I just know my yeah you know exactly
what you're doing 30 minutes that's not
too bad would you do eyelashes if you're
just like on a day [ __ ] going to work
vibe
yeah I normally have like permanent like
lash extensions where you you get them
like refilled
so you don't skip it like for a month or
yeah they'll they'll be all gone by so
cool I keep getting eyelash
darkeners all over my face that's what
these are for yes
for it
also like you need to use your left hand
and I'm really
you don't no you use your right hand
okay whatever I'm out
take your lip liner lip liner yeah
that's the pink lips wait I want to get
hold up show me this can I get this off
with the
this is not oh it is coming up
okay I've got a lip liner
this is basically lipstick this one yeah
and I want you to line your lips go out
just a little farther than or your lip
toe so like where your lip is raised and
the white is you know what I'm talking
about that's where you want to line so
you've got a lot of hair there but I'll
do one where do I do I do it like your
um the outer the outer rim of your lips
okay just I'm outlining the outers okay
love that
foreign
one God we will
like use our finger to smudge it out and
then we have
lip plumper extreme which will tingle a
lot and makes your lips super it tingles
are you serious yeah oh my God
what is in that thing
lip plumper it makes them bigger it has
okay so it has a safe cancer it has safe
ingredients that irritate your lips to a
point where it adds color and what
volume that sounds good man how do you
feel about that no I'm not sure I mean
whatever radioactive isotopes in that I
mean people put it on every day I guess
so can't be that bad right
uh so line your lips first I'm using it
I'm lined up I'm gonna rub it in I did I
did a few lines don't rub it out if
you're blending it in in okay yeah yeah
yeah and stay inside your lip got it
Gotta Get It Smart Genius
okay then
you see the lip plumper
what does it look like it has a gold top
it's little we're looking to get plumped
up why don't you just give me a b I'll
let it sting my lips yeah I'm I'm afraid
to do this I'm doing my lips are pretty
after the outline pick your finger if
you feel like it needs to be Blended a
little blend it out and then it looks
like a syringe just like this thing what
does it look like uh cut to me
it's here Golden Top right here it's not
that oh this oh this one Golden Top with
some lube inside all right well and I
just put this on my lips and they get
all [ __ ] big how long does it last
um okay
like an hour maybe is there any warning
on this
yo it says this may cause cancer
does it what doesn't no it doesn't I'm
just kidding just kidding how much do we
put on this do we like
um
this is my lip plumper lip gloss yep
that's good religiously every single day
it is my favorite Beauty thing that I
own really I thought it hurts so bad the
first time I use it I've never used it
okay what you like the potato you like
the feeling now yeah now I do yeah
that's crazy I've never what happens if
you put it somewhere else on your body
what about if I put that on my dick
that would be a mistake
do you have a dick plumper that would be
a bad idea
I'm just saying for working on the lift
our tree
I'm in pain
[Laughter]
I'm down to try the lip plumper better I
don't have any can I use it I just put
it on my whole lips thank you Sam you
look stomach yeah I think just kind of
you gloss it up baby do you want me to
fix it
okay can you
glued on so it wouldn't [ __ ] it up
and then I just kind of gloss this on if
you put it on your lips
[Music]
I don't feel anything yet does it take a
minute
foreign
don't worry
oh yeah I feel it it's starting
okay I'm plumped now same here
should I wash this off my hands is this
like poisonous reaction begins yeah
I think it's just because
okay Eli you look great and I ended up
really bad
all right it's strong
strong yeah
thank you yeah you look awesome Mila
holy [ __ ] I put so much on my I don't
feel anything on my lips my bad baby
no no it's okay I put some extra after
you did I don't feel a damn thing me
neither maybe put more okay thank you
thank you is this one maybe this
some wet wipes
okay
was that the last step was that it
really I don't feel anything I'm
starting to feel a little bit of a
tingle here
how long has it been a minute ago
easily
without more oh [ __ ] I feel mine
yeah me too if it hurts oh
I love it it does kind of Sting I don't
know I don't feel anything really I want
to feel the burn I think you will my
lips look plump though I'm starting to
feel like a really light light look at
it
[Laughter]
oh no I look so [ __ ] good oh no my
makeup Channel dreams are dead
oh my God oh my God how long how long
does this take I don't feel anything I
feel like tiny bit now mine is
definitely burning well maybe he gets
the worst of everything oh my lips are
so [ __ ] big all right
oh my God
oh my God the [ __ ] wait you're freaking
out are you serious wait how bad can it
be
let me see over these [ __ ] fake
eyelashes I don't know I know how do you
get your music
okay let's look at everyone's lip Dan
look up
slay yes okay my lips are starting to
burn a little bit now we want to give
people grades on their makeup that
sounds like a great big pictures too
because yeah I mean you look so good
do we have um
should we have the fans vote for their
faves yeah uh sure although um the
normal YouTube vote is not enough so
we'll do one should we do one person at
a time or does that take too long I was
just gonna do the straw poll thing that
lets you do more yeah you're right let's
just do that and then people can vote
for their fave yeah
whoa what was that abru alive
him
what was that flash a straw pull button
is linked to this right now did I do
that
you got a Wally button I don't know
where that came
it's kind of fitting yeah
okay okay yeah I feel it now I want an
AB lip update
maybe oh [ __ ] let's bust those socks I'm
a little afraid
dude I cannot tell if my vision is
skewed from the eyelashes or they're
[ __ ] huge
they look big no they look they are big
but it's the lip liner too baby
they definitely look big you got some
big ass lips brother I didn't wear I
didn't put on the lip liner
oh you didn't no all right let's so who
all did it yeah I think I got everybody
Ethan E look Danny B Zach Lena and cam
right as Dan's setting up the poll let's
get one good long shot of everybody so
let's go ahead by one by one and you can
switch between us
yeah
there it is
assistant Dan
Zach was looks like looks like an orphan
yes Oliver Twist of vibes
Lena can you look yeah look at that okay
whip your hair cam
oh God
something happened man in that other eye
okay
look how good you look the eyelashes are
kind of a Vibe yeah I've never seen it
with Long Island I've never done it I
mean obviously they're super exaggerated
yeah
um so for this uh poll are we doing just
who has the best makeup like is that the
way to do it who do you like the best
you like the best probably not even best
job we took the biggest sleigh pill yeah
who took the biggest
sleigh Hill I can allow people to answer
uh like multiple
of ranked choice you can't do ranked
choice but you can get like let them
pick like three people they can pick two
people all right everybody can pick two
people a loud selection of multiple
options two okay I think this is good to
go then let me get it going
okay
create pool
yeah my lips are tingling yeah do they
look bigger though
I can't tell because you also have the
lip liner all right I am putting out the
pole I'm gonna pin the pole in the chat
and I'm also gonna spam it
I'm in the pool
oh [ __ ] so it should it should let you
pick two can somebody test that I don't
know yeah love can you go can you do the
poll and just make sure it seems like
it's working properly yep all right well
well that was so fun that actually took
so [ __ ] long yeah how long have we
been going Dan
uh let's see we're at two hours and 22
minutes holy
yeah we did the whole goddamn episode
well we're gonna obviously talk about
more but
Jesus
all right everyone straw pulls in the
chat guys yeah and let me uh now do you
clean all your brushes after every time
yeah oh yeah I guess hold on hold on
yeah please guys
I'm not as good you guys can one sec
please okay sorry yeah it's just it's so
hard to listen on their side two
conversations going on at the same time
on the mic
um
okay as this is populating yeah you you
can I'm curious what her answer was to
your question
she kind of said not really because oh
do I wash do you wash every time I'm not
good at that
oh [ __ ] it says you or someone on your
Wi-Fi has already voted
ah yeah it's limits okay are you saying
what's Happening Here Ela
you are easily winning a b in second oh
a b yeah okay me and Zach down at the
bottom damn poor oh Cam Ethan I tried I
tried Lena listen I tried what can I do
but ela's taking the uh thank you she's
taking I mean what can I say Gee let's
say I really tried though I feel like
some of you guys were kind of like being
silly about it so you know what's funny
I was being silly and then it looked
good yeah when I started really trying
I was like oh damn and then uh all
downhill
thank you that was wow of course Olivia
Olivia thank you
what a play you we should tweet all
these out um yeah
uh uh AV how can I open this dude these
actually okay this is actually really
good
you can actually thinking yeah I mean
it's for the office I'm gonna take off
the eyelashes because this is the worst
this is the worst
ow all right well now that we're all
glamified let's do the the show I mean
okay yeah
um I have a gajillion Discord
notifications from AV
I got you
all right well let's move on uh there's
so much to talk about and uh so little
time
uh we talked about
um
yilong ma there's a new year long ma
video
oh dude this is so interesting Ila you
don't know about this yeah we made
contact with yilong ma hi and he big
time does hard
oh he [ __ ] big time does here let's
watch the news and then I'll read you
the messages Zach had with them
so let's see what he's up to
what
hi everyone
um I
younger
English is so easy uh what's it issue
what I'm not sure what he's saying uh he
said his English is very good oh
he's doing my favorite a lot I don't
know if he watched us because he's just
playing up the uh a lot yeah
just keep watching you'll see
um
[Laughter]
it's just a continuous thing
it's so funny
uh what no follow me
he was like totally lost that was the
wildest one yet oh what is that oh my
God all right so this guy
Zach how did you find their contact info
um Twitter so I I well Twitter link to
his Tick Tock and I um message him you
know gave him the Spiel and
um he responded to me in Mandarin so
every message I had to translate and I'm
assuming he was doing the same for for
years right right right so this this
took place on WhatsApp though looks like
uh telegram so this is not this is not a
conversation between me and Elon to my
uh understanding he he put me on to his
what translated out to be his broker or
like his manager so this is me speaking
to his manager I love that he's got a
manager
okay well here it is so um he says uh
Zach says name your price and we can go
from there let's make this work
wait oh wait this isn't the first one
I'm here priced about what so what
happened was he deleted the whole
message conversation in telegram so
bring me up until now so yeah that's it
that's all I have that's all I have but
what did you guys what did you guys talk
before that
oh just like hey you know uh gave him
the Spiel again and he kept saying I
need good faith offer from you
uh what did you guys want him to call in
or something yeah I just want to say hi
just a quick call
um and he kept uh he kept make it very
money driven and then he said um
you need us we don't need you along
something along the lines of that yeah
he cut that part yeah yeah he says we
need you you need us more than we need
you wow okay Yi long so he says name
Zach says name your price we can go for
that let's make it work forget it don't
waste each other's time thank you wow
give me an offer Zach said 200 you are
really funny this is the funniest joke I
have heard this year
tell me a price 2 000 Yuan which is I
think like almost 300 bucks right yeah
yeah
I was like that's that's fair you know
that's [ __ ] a fair price for a quick
call one I don't know dude I mean it
should be for free I think he deserves
more
before I call in dude he is the world's
richest man after all yeah he's a Elon
Ma
how much should I pay him
250 bucks for 10 minutes
I chip in with 50. 750
750.50 I'm not paying his ass especially
when he's being a dick
no you're such a dick I'm on inside here
maybe he's dedicated yeah maybe he's
dedicated to the character and wants to
be paid in Dogecoin
regular Fiats I offered him 300 bucks I
really think it's um it might be a
cultural thing with him like it's like
you have to give him the best offer for
him to come on
I thought that the CH or I I don't want
to make I'm not even gonna say it I
thought they were more open to
negotiating the in that culture like
here in America there's less haggling
right it's like the price of the price
button a lot of other cultures they
expect the haggling to take place right
so I'm just I I don't know why he
wouldn't name me an offer I don't know
why he wouldn't give me a price people
are saying he deserves more can we can
we do a poll or a call in it's just a
10-minute call-in
you just calls into Zoom
he the processing power to do a live
deep fake is it needs a lot of money no
he's not deep fake I wanna I wanted to
see what he really looked like you think
you could do a live deep fake yeah if
he's
if we're paying him that then he must
well if he said that I would have said
okay fine if you're using a super
computer to Crunch the numbers I'll pay
you he should have just told me how much
you wanted yeah I don't I don't
understand why he won't I'm gonna hit
him up again just wait I haven't heard
from him yeah we could give a guy 50
bucks and put an Elon filter on him and
call it a day and just pretend he's
yield long I don't need you [ __ ] you
need me
I'll put a Elon filter on
I think love has a shoot ice love has an
Elon filter I think yeah about let's see
a lot of processing power I come can't
run it right now I'll send you 2 000
Yuan bro
[Music]
it's like really hard okay all right I'm
not kidding I'm not kidding
uh 500. yeah
all right fine you play you run a hard
bargain 10 000 Yuan
oh [ __ ] Albert I'll set it up for next
film all right so there it is so uh are
you long my dreams are over I'm sad to
say but I'm not gonna give up I'm not
gonna give up he ghosted you he's like
pissed you're like insulted
not gonna give up I'm still gonna try oh
can you choose
all right well we'll just Zach work your
magic and we'll see you got it
this was funny
um
we had talking about how much of
keemstar's face he covers
and someone actually I just have to
respect the math you know there's that
subreddit they did the math
well
someone actually calculated the pixels
and green is exposed and red is covered
and they calculated 82 percent coverage
so
they did the math only 18 exposed and my
thesis is that and it works the same for
me the more you cover the better you
look
so so shout out 82 coverage that's
that's pretty impressive
I would be I would be interested to know
if you could find someone with higher
percentage coverage than that
I'd like to possibly give him the
Guinness World Record for that one
but uh anyway shout out to the subreddit
for that one
yeah
and then uh okay so let's do this
Twitter segment and I've been dying to
go over this it's so good
and we've got that we've got Nick Cannon
um had his 20th baby
oh I want to talk about the Nikita
Dragon thing too
okay let's we're gonna have to get
through all this we've got so much to do
all right Twitter update so guys let's
let me open this since Elon opened the
impersonation Gates
it's so funny he I don't really know
what he said that offering verification
to everyone would reduce scams and Bots
and I don't understand how that is
possible because all it did was
people just went ape [ __ ] with it they
make a new account
and they buy verification and as I
showed you guys in the beginning that
one um
pharmaceutical company tanked like three
billion dollars because of it so here's
Nintendo of America
uh Mario uh flipping off the camera
he's so cool I'm sure they appreciated
that
that is insanely well made by the way
or they just had a finger to his fist I
don't know
uh we have here Tesla a verified account
Tesla real they got the hand like the
handles they're getting are so good
um breaking a second Tesla has hit the
World Trade Center
that is breaking news my God
uh
another one from Tesla
definitely do not go to this website and
see how many times our cars catch on
fire tesla-fire.com
actually is that safe to visit I can
check it out I actually do want to know
that now
more from Tesla real we'll be offering
10 000 vehicles to support the Ukrainian
military how generous our cars are the
most advanced explosive devices on the
market okay okay I see what's going on
here
foreign
if it's not running over kids it's
blowing up is yeah just a question okay
cool yeah
um another one appreciation post for our
amazing Founders yeah oh no that's
that's G Lane Maxwell that's not
I don't think she had anything to do
with Tesla I know I mean that's the
official account I don't know is this it
is verified verified that's real so uh
that website
looks okay I mean it's just like a XL
sheet with like fatel
Tesla fires 134 known cases of Tesla's
spontaneously combusting oh my God
wow they really did this the
descriptions
okay let's see description mega fire
closes down the highway one
Tesla catches on fire while driving
Tesla history Wow Car catches on fire on
dude this is serious elon's got to be
loving this and this is verified so
that's going to show up in your verified
tab
float to the top of every response
um O.J Simpson
this is interesting uh verified it says
yeah I'm not gonna lie I did that [ __ ] I
love now that's nice
finally and what's so good about this
handle is that OJ's is the real OJ 32
it's almost identical this guy got the
real and elon's like yeah this is what I
want Twitter to be
like this is almost completely
indistinguishable from the real account
and the verification process is just
terrific legally I think that's a
confession is it not yeah
the thing is he can't be can he I don't
think he can't be tried yeah you already
got uh they already Double Jeopardy yeah
yeah I mean he wrote a book called if I
did if I did it
I don't think he's hiding it at this
point
um Roblox yo look at this handle Roblox
us that's insane we're adding sex to
Roblox misspelling adding which adds a
lot to the experience
like this is insane
I have to think that Twitter
headquarters is just unindated with
lawyer letters complaints buyers I mean
oh this is such a [ __ ] show
yo this is the banana company Chiquita
yeah
Chiquita Brands like it looks super
legit we've just overdone
banana money's big they could actually
do that well look at scroll down one
more the follow-up tweets even better
Chiquita we apologize to those who have
uh been served a misleading message from
a fake Chiquita account we have not
overthrown a government since
1954. but wait this isn't the real one
no it's the same fake account
but it his at is different this says
Chiquita Brands and this oh maybe the
first one got banned and then they did
another one but he spelled it right
it might be an edit it must have been
edited
okay oh this is good uh BP Global the uh
gas company uh they says we just killed
the planet doesn't mean just because we
killed the planet doesn't mean we can't
miss it well that's nice to know that
they care uh the handle is bpd's nuts
game freak us
verified account
yeah you can [ __ ] the Pokemon in the new
one
fire I'm finally up you know murdered is
so funny you know I thought Pokemon was
falling off a little bit their new games
weren't that exciting but okay now I'm
interested now back in now that's a game
freak actually
shout out to Ash Ketchum today he won
the World Championship yeah what the
[ __ ] does that mean I saw people
tweeting about that I just the whole
point of Pokemon is he's always trying
to be the champion of the world and I
guess he won today in whatever episode
was released so is it over is the show
over I doubt it
I just think he's not like a virgin
anymore you're gonna [ __ ] a Pokemon yeah
also I have an update the second tweet
they have a blue check because they're
notable in government news entertainment
or other distinguished categories for a
while wait no the banana the banana oh
the banana wait so that was the second
banana no way no no no it's just an edit
it's an edit picture is just an edit I
got it oh the picture that is the true
account they must have edited off
[Music]
um game freak okay oh by the way I
forgot to thank tan man for the gift
thank you so much can I get a birthday
shout out from my girlfriend
happy birthday Queen I thought it was
free speech it is nope that one costs
money
um Ted Cruz
at creative [ __ ] the first time oh my
God ticker is verified the first time I
entered my human wife I said groaning
into her ear this is exactly how mother
said it would feel oh my God and then a
Ben Shapiro verified I love my human
wife
you know it's this is amazing this is
such a [ __ ] though and he says verified
accounts Twitter blue they rise to the
top
and without clicking their profile
there's no way to know that it's a bank
account and it's just unusable
has there been any updates because I
know they stopped selling Twitter blue
today they brought back the the white
badge the second the second yeah this is
verified
the one that you were official or the
one that says official the original one
the one yeah they just added another
check mark and this new one is mean but
then they removed it but then today they
brought it back so they flip-flopped on
it so now there's a new check mark but
no blue but no blue so the one that I
had from before yeah I don't have it now
now you should have the video that
that'll still be there because that's in
addition to the Twitter
wait are you official can you check
yours I don't know I could check it if
you want yeah check it tell me if it was
official
I bet you're official bro it's still
there I think they grandfathered you in
oh
get this unofficial well she's blue but
I'm not seeing the white official one oh
that's [ __ ] up I've seen the white one
oh you see it yeah it's just everybody's
getting a different result yeah it's not
going great different for my phone and
my PCS
that's why I was messing around the
other day I tweeted uh imagine paying
for verification because I do have some
people would see that I have it and the
other half wouldn't and it would just
create chaos yeah great because some
people thought it was serious and the
other ones I was messing around Good
Times
um Hassan retweeted this one Donald J
Trump real Donald Trump
who are playing but they worm
good question Donnie yeah bench bear
responded to Ted he says this is
verified of course oh my God you got me
kind of horny right now Mr Cruz Ted Cruz
response verified have you ever tasted
the intros of a man Ben there are no
Cardinal Pleasures as delectable okay
interesting that's so interesting
conversation he goes on Ted Cruz
verified
I am pro-life because I Feast on
neglected babies nine months after a
prom night I wandered the streets and
checked dumpsters for dinner and you
will not believe how fresh and how sweet
the meat is
that's verified Ted Cruz interesting to
admit that publicly Ted but yeah
glad I know
um Chuck Grassley
and a verified of course U.S senator
yeah and the tando looks legit rashley
Chuck E been dead for four years I would
be doing a Weekend at Bernie's with me
you know
Mr Bean real Mr Bean that's a real hand
though oh my God if you clicked him into
their profile I think that's the real Mr
Bean
he says who wants me to really eat their
[ __ ] tonight
I feel like the actual mistake yeah
no that was real yeah that one's real
you know he'd get real animated with his
mannerism imagine him down there
he'd be looking up like this
being all goofy about it
be like that
I don't know
uh continuing
U.S Department of Education okay cool us
or gov please to announce that all
current loan balances with the
Department of Education have been
reduced to zero thank you to the
generous donation for Mr musk we applaud
him for his dedication to making
education accessible for all more
details to come hashtag student loan
forgiveness uh well that's generous I
think I had to put put out a clarifying
tweet that you do still have to be uh
making payments
Dave Chappelle
real Chappelle d
oh wow verified trans women are women no
longer team Turf y'all but that's nice
yeah that's a nice Evolution I love that
that's like still obviously a fake and
being like I don't have trans people
yeah Eli Lilly this one we talked about
we're excited to announce insulin is
free their stock lost a several billion
dollars from the result of this fake
tweet so fantastic
what do we got here uh maybe so these
are my analytics uh they've gone up
significantly since I've gotten Twitter
blue of course we talked about it on the
show so I wonder how much that has to do
with it but
when we've talked about it before it
hasn't grown like this
so they definitely are pushing it so
what but did you have like a banger
tweet or something I mean no no really
can I be honest go ahead look I've seen
a crazy increase on Twitter too and I
think it's because you're banned Ethan
that people are looking to fall oh yeah
well yeah you can follow the guys but
the show podcast if you want show
updates that's where we're going to do
it yeah I'm not doing it not my account
I don't got nothing to do with that okay
that's interesting well there you go um
what do you think lots of new followers
for the crew
what do you think because there's like
Twitter
um shareholders right not anymore he's
the one he's owner got delisted so he
just bought the whole thing he one dude
owns Twitter does and decides everything
it's his private business is delisted
from the stock market nobody can tell
him [ __ ] okay yeah and he's doing he's
just taking it down he's just yeah whoa
wait what like your makeup I got a
little bored and I you just did that
that's so cool I like it yeah I like it
just didn't expect it you want a
tutorial that's really cool maybe next
time when we had a Long Prairie long
enough tutorial for today
this is more me my inner self I like
that you should tat your face up [ __ ] it
uh maybe yeah so can the do you think
that everybody that left Twitter because
a lot of Executives left right yes could
they all go and start their own Twitter
the real Twitter they could but it
requires a lot of capital dude they I
don't think so it would I mean
theoretically anyone could eventually
yeah but the thing is um
it just costs a lot of money to compete
they would call it Twitter real and
practices not parody
not a joke serious
yeah I can't believe this dump man
that's crazy
and also this is a time when the stock
market went up like five percent and
they dropped
3.3
oh that's awesome that's just awesome
260 likes it's so funny
uh so now they've brought back the
official check mark we talked about that
now here's where I'm saying we had a
little bit of a disagreement a lot of
the conservo Spheres and Ethan haters
out there and Tim Poole oh and Ninja
I thought comedy was alive
come [ __ ] me in the ass and it's not
funny hey hey wife do you want to watch
Elon [ __ ] me in the ass
bunny
Ninja's my worst enemy bro
would you forgive him if he apologized
immediately
that's very Wheezy already forgiven
so the real Elon Musk uh tweets and this
is the real Elon Musk are we sure can we
confirm that this is the real unbox I
just don't know anymore I don't think it
is is because it doesn't say real yeah
yeah it's verified it's got the picture
but are you sure this isn't like a one
or an at capital i
how do we know
yeah it's the real one he says going
forward
and counts engaging in parity must
include parody in their name not just in
the bio he tweeted this yesterday
[ __ ] yep so what the [ __ ] does
that mean that I was compliant going
forward where's what the [ __ ]
yeah
I agree that that's what that seems to
imply I went if I think it's in that
same album if you scroll down you'll see
his original tweet where's all the all
the crybabies saying like oh all of a
sudden you can't read instructions you
can't read the guideline well that's
what everyone was telling me or yeah I
mean well here Billy D he's a ninja he's
confirming right here yeah he's saying
that that wasn't the case yes
yes and so I'm suing Twitter for
violating My Free Speech First Amendment
uh if I go down this was his original
tweet or he says to be more precise
accounts doing parody impersonations
basically tricking people is not okay
okay whatever Elon you tricked me that
you're a competent business person so
[ __ ] what are you gonna do about it
uh that's right
we're doing a parody subscript to
clarify I don't know what that means
thanks mate and um
what is this just Clowning first oh
that's funny it is kind of
I heard that there's a movement now
where they're banning or that people are
blocking anyone that paid for it sure
because it's just destroying their feed
right the the verified
um notifications yeah it's just all on
that
ratio why is nobody defending me though
why is no everyone not talking about me
look at this
this account is verified because it's
subscribed to Twitter
it's awesome I love the bullying of
people who paid for this
am I oh this is I thought this was an
imp [ __ ] me
I thought this was an immature album you
all wanted me to read that [ __ ] I was
like how far is this go
okay
um here's his original tweet
here's the original tweet that's what I
just said
thanks Jeremy that's literally what I
said dude
going forward any Twitter handle
engaging impersonation without clearly
specifying parody will be permanently
suspended I put it in this banner I put
it in the description right so this this
first read that he said he said handle
which uh it's debatable that doesn't
mean that the handle is the at
uh specifically that is also like you as
a user right so it doesn't this doesn't
say the parody needs to be in the handle
you could read it either way yeah it's
ambiguous and this could be the handle I
mean I don't this is just the name yeah
I don't know I mean the the textbook
definition I looked it up even on
Twitter's uh page like if you look up
what is a Twitter handle
here
yeah you're smart Olivia by the way is
posting this under all of abn's exposed
every single and I think that's real
important Zach after I said that posted
an rip to someone and I could not who'd
you rest in peace to uh HomeTown Buffet
what it's just not that serious it's
humped down Buffet it's still I saw
R.I.P and I was like I can't I can't too
soon man what happened to Hometown yes
she was not around anymore dude they're
going out of business they've been out
of business no way yeah since the panty
dude wow I don't think I've ever eaten
there oh dude you missed out did I did
no it's it's a world of it's like
Disneyland for
Foodies Foodies what do you get what do
you fill up on [ __ ] I was talking to Ian
about it the mac and cheese the Fried
Chicken they got everything man oh and
it's good it doesn't matter no no rest
in peace I'd give for a [ __ ] chicken
strip from the booth man
rip rip to the uh to the Goot
baby was right I am glad that I had you
pay for my account because Olivia can't
post that under mine yeah that's on me
yeah wait so Olivia if what if I like
undo the Twitter blue but it takes a
month for the check mark to go away you
guys know that check mark is gone you're
getting this meme agreed did you guys
talk about how Zach and Ian can't change
their name I don't know if I missed that
one said oh that's another funny thing
Elon did so he's convincing trying to
convince people to pay for this [ __ ] and
he's like how do I stop impersonating
because everyone's verified I didn't
think that about this at all here's my
CL my idea everyone who pays me now
can't change their name or picture great
so you pay and you have less options and
you're stuck so Zach is stuck as Zach
Lewis live at the Troubadour and uh Ian
says what is Jersey in McDuck
[Music]
that's okay it's nice
but anyway I think his new tweet
clarifies that I was compliant
I mean that's just what it is bro
so take this l
ol
um
Elon Musk despite Twitter he claims
being at all-time high
traffic as telling whatever employees
are left at Twitter that the company is
close to going bankrupt
um
yeah it's been two weeks
44 billion
it's just been 44 billion dollars two
weeks in yeah we might have to declare
bankruptcy
this if that happens this will be like
probably the biggest business fail in
human history I don't it's up there
it will be kind of a great lesson for
all the kids out there that like
even somebody like Elon Musk can make a
mistake
don't be impulsive an expensive mistake
don't be arrogant and impulsive so
arrogant the way that like he just took
it on doing stuff without any thought
fire that fire everybody that actually
knows what they're doing just assuming
that he knows better than everybody that
ran this company so far totally he was
like dude I can do this but it's stupid
and now it's just melting down
so let's see he warns employees of
80-hour weeks lost perks
investors were already offering
distressed prices for loans
um
please leave me alone let's see
uh he says uh um the warning
came basically he was telling people
they have to work in the office now at
least 40 weeks 40 days [ __ ]
40 hours a week what's that he told
their employees they have to work a
minimum of 40 hours a week
in the office like in person a lot of
Twitter employees worked remotely yeah
because why why do you need to be in
office I have no idea but he's insisting
on it what and they they have one day
notice on that by the way
and he's expecting them to work 80 hour
weeks though
but that's just psycho so he he fired 75
percent of the people the 25 percent of
the people he's saying you have to work
twice as hard now
to cover the slack but it's like you're
working on stuff that you don't need to
physically be there It's All Digital he
disagrees
yeah and now top executives are leaving
actually this is kind of a I need an
abridgement of this it's kind of hard to
I had put I'd put two little blurbs that
just seemed like the most interesting
Parts uh musk loaded the company with
almost 13 billion of debt and now it's
in the hands of seven Wall Street banks
that have been unable to offload to
investors
confidence the company has eroded so
rapidly that even before must bankruptcy
comment some funds were offering to buy
the loan for as little as 60 cents on
the dollar price typically reserved for
com companies deemed in financial
distress I mean they are in financial
distress
yeah
and then for some reason a Twitter was
all in Mandarin yesterday
I saw that the trending page yeah and I
was like this is weird and then all of
everyone was like yo why is my feed all
in Mandarin
oh
so everything's going great and the top
Executives there there was this one
safety and policy guy he was kept quote
tweeting and he was being like yeah
we're working on it everything's going
in the right direction the executive and
it just came out like yesterday the day
before that he resigned and another one
of the executives resigned to
so this is spectacular
so I'm following along and you know when
it all went South when he Banned Me
that was the beginning that was the
beginning
yep I say respect to those that resigned
oh yeah is this loser you don't need to
work for him look in this working in
this Marketplace the power is with the
worker they're in high paying jobs or
high training jobs in our field with
those fashion yeah people the power is
all with the employees they and and
today people come with a request and
most of them do a request for a hybrid
work situation where at least they can
work from home like two days a week or
something and two days in the office or
whatever and like yeah especially if
what you do is digital I don't see why
not come on the only like
when we worked physically with samples
which is some positions in our company
then you know it's like you need to be
there for that but even with those
people who are able to figure it out
I don't see
over at Dan and Dan's doing the same
[ __ ] going right in the corner
yeah did you wash it off or something
you already took a little bit I tried to
get it off a little bit with the wet
water great I'm used to it yeah well I
took off the eyelashes but the residual
glue is making my eyelids like stick
together constantly and I have to like
do this to pop them open it's super easy
if you like grab a string and just pull
it'll come off super easy
yes so um basically I think he's really
[ __ ] because he's he's fired 75 of a
highly skilled Workforce yeah they're
gonna go easily find another job
somewhere else and then what's crazy is
the 25 that he's left he's now asking to
work twice as hard and get less benefits
and worse working environment they have
no reason to stay there they can easily
go find a a job in any other tech
company and with better conditions make
you more whatever and without the stress
of this and then when he realizes he
needs people back he's gonna have a
really hard time getting anyone to go
work there like who's going to want to
jump on that sinking ship
it's crazy his uh his little Elon Sims
well the thing is I don't know how many
of them are qualified to actually work
on Twitter the thing is he is notorious
for exploiting his Workforce but the
difference is that with SpaceX and Tesla
the people believe in them their mission
and their willing to say I believe in
this and so I'm gonna and he exploited
that he did but with Twitter nobody
gives a [ __ ] it's just Twitter like
that's a job you work and you get paid
for nobody's trying you know what I mean
yeah so I don't think that his normal
shtick of exploiting his Workforce is
going to work in that case yeah
rattle her Rat Hole yeah so that's my
take on all that pretty good stuff
Nick Cannon by the way just had his 12th
child
with the different women
that's a third child who announced it I
don't believe oh he's announced yeah so
he's had three
babies with three different women this
year and get this his child support bill
is apparently three million dollars a
year
ha
that's kind of wait that's kind of like
how much is that per baby mama per kid
though because that's can we put a cap
on how many kids people can have divided
by 13. I mean he's paying each mom 230
000. a year I mean I guess that's I mean
if you're rich I guess that makes sense
you just got he's got to stop having
kids
I guess 230 a year is a lot but like you
know that's that's
what's happening back there
what's they be saying I don't know
yeah I know
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah so we made this little Stinger so
anytime
um Nick Cannon has another baby we can
just swipe in the new face put up the
number and then also what can we do um
cam is add the child support number and
then just add another
30 per
yeah that'd be helpful but you got to
keep someone's got to keep track of this
he's probably not yeah he's got to tune
into our show to find out how many kids
he's got
what is going on here I don't know it's
so disturbing why are these girls or
women still they get 2 30 a year get
pregnant with him
and why is he so obsessed with having
kids can somebody stop sex it's really
weird I mean I know there's some
religions than like cultish kind of
mormony [ __ ] that I've learned about
where they think that um
having a lot of kids is Godly having a
lot of kids is like status and all this
kind of stuff so I don't know I know
he's I think he's Muslim though so I'm
not sure if
if is it is that are you supposed to
have like a gajillion kids yeah I hope
not because I'm [ __ ] up no I'm not
yeah you're way behind bro it's a
cultural thing you know just Arabs not
to have a lot though it's just to get
married and have children uh throughout
your life yeah it's never like if you
have a certain number especially some
people can't you know
um take care of that many so coming from
the girl with six siblings well it is
common to in Arab families to have yeah
to be like a little bit bigger but I
don't think they're trying for that but
also we just looked it up I don't know
where you got the Muslim thing from he's
not Muslim but it is oh he's not no not
according to this I just Googled it wait
what's his real is he Christian the
Canon is not a Muslim he's a committed
Christian he spoke about a Christian
relationship in which
yeah okay my bad but also he's actively
having kids with different women and
like that's not traditional yeah that's
what I'm saying like that's not like
yeah my my parents also were in kind a
religious leaning families and they were
big but it's like they're committed to
their family yeah you have a central
unit of does he even spend time with the
kids hell no does he even know their
names do they have Thanksgiving inside
of a gymnasium
that [ __ ] needs Dodger Stadium
to have a family gathering it's just so
weird
yeah it's [ __ ] up those kids are not
going to be good uh well just to
um that's super weird super crazy and
just selfish it's gross I mean kids they
need if they need their parents it's
just weird and gross and I hate it and I
wish you would stop
yeah he could make his own Drumline
he's gonna have his own basketball he
can just do a whole basketball uh
tournament now
with that
um the three million dollars uh uh was
calculated by taking into account
several factors including Nick's status
as a high income earner sure
so yeah the lawyer explained that net
worth does not get taken into account
but his yearly income does
if he is taking home somewhere around 5
million a year which is totally possible
is he still doing like America's Got
Talent like what is his day job
I'm not sure let me look yeah no he's
not on AGT anymore he's not no
because that's what I assumed his his
paycheck was coming from just sex the
makeup is something funny no
not at all bro
yeah
I don't know
he's gonna end up in jail for like not
being able to pay child support he's
executive producer on The Masked Singer
and uh executive producer of wild and
out
oh that's what he's up to right now okay
I don't know if that's gonna end up to
five million dollars a year
my best singer show is pretty big yeah
they had Rudy Giuliani
yeah that's true
um so if he's making five million a year
you have to look at what it would take
to have the children kept in the
lifestyle of both parents God he's so
[ __ ]
maybe he wants to go jail maybe he's
just trying to escape if I have more
kids
maybe I can just get put in jail and get
away from all this
yep
there that is
did you bring condoms
no he clearly did not and he never will
and uh if he would make less child
support would be less yeah
so you're saying it's calculated based
on his his yearly income so he'll go
down if he made less money
yeah that's my guess
because I've heard of something
happening like uh who's the guy in the
whale that everyone loves oh Brandon
yeah because what he went through a
really notorious breakup where his
ex-wife was making like more money than
he had and he went like bankrupt
it was really crazy story that stuff
does happen sometimes
um
somebody said I heard he's sick that's
why he's having so many kids I mean he's
mentally ill I don't know about like
physically ill well he's been through a
lot I'm also one of those people that
love him
um but yeah I mean it's a lot to get
into but he's he's doing better seems
you love him I do love him with the
Mommy it's a very important movie to my
family money uh
that one mm-hmm love that one
you love you love everybody you have
you're such a fan and I appreciate that
about you I'm the opposite yeah I don't
but you I know you think I do but but
you do
Nick Cannon not
mechanics talking about Brendan Fraser
oh Brendan Frasier okay that makes more
sense I thought you like I like Nick
Cannon I was like you're the only one
yeah all right yeah I thought that's
what you were saying too
[Laughter]
yo we gotta make that a thing maybe we
got if you get a picture with the
celebrity we got it that's just
everything by the way did you pay to
sponsor the one of us together yeah I
did how much you dropping that
you know honestly I forgot I wonder if
it's still going check oh my God
thirty dollars a day no 30 in total
didn't get you any new followers no it's
here dude their problem sucks bro I
tried doing marketing on Teddy fresh on
Instagram and it's like you can spend
all the friends it doesn't do anything I
don't know understand how they make
money from that [ __ ] I don't know it got
yeah I just sent it it got 23 000.
yeah yeah here's AB
with me captive of course a very present
and uh and he sponsored it
how much do you have left in ad credit
as Jessenia asked that's a good question
no he dipped into his own pocket for
that one
23 000 though that's pretty good
you want to lose some money today not
good enough not good enough I mean my
first one was Ian which wasn't sponsored
did a lot better than that
me
what do you what's what are you trying
to say bro I'm just saying I don't know
pull it up how many how many likes to
get uh
yeah I was right after
why would you first of all it's been up
longer you got to give mine a little
[ __ ] time to catch up but for you to
[ __ ] sit here
I was actually asked to promote my
Pokemon post too you got to do it bro
nah hell no you got to promote it let
him know
53 bucks dude you'll get one nude
follower
yeah I have I have a photo with Pokey
that I never posted a sponsor I was
thinking about posting and sponsoring
but you want to creep her out
yeah don't do that she has enough creeps
am I right love wait is this is this
from you baby no that's for me what is
this from because I did the teddy bear
uh picture after a B's you've got 500
new followers yeah oh that's actually
pretty good yeah not bad but I mean for
50 bucks it's not worth it that's that's
10 followers per dollar that's that's
super good I'd rather just I think Ryan
Kavanaugh pays more than that yeah dude
allegedly Minecraft Roblox hold on I got
one should I mean should I promote this
one me with the boys let me see
yo Ryan camera probably is like a
hundred dollars per new 1.3 million yeah
this is this is real
uh yeah
I think people would be like what the
[ __ ] it actually might drive people to
be like who is this and why is this on
my page the next president right there
dude look at me you had 1700 visits from
the ad and converted 500 of them
to following that's pretty good I think
that is insane yeah that's like back
when I did add ads that [ __ ] is like you
I'd pay probably a [ __ ] thousand
bucks for that listen if we no one gives
a [ __ ] about me
you know what's funny about Boby what we
didn't say
he showed the clip of the was it the Ben
Shapiro thing
I don't know what you're talking he got
banned for showing the clip he got
banned oh for reporting on your band and
then he got banned right okay
oh that's a real one
that's [ __ ] awesome oh it wasn't
Bobby oh
wasn't he Bobby uh I I banned for two
weeks or something I heard I've
remembered I am seeing that he was
I always thought let's see got banned
for okay well whatever yeah
yeah okay love that Kobe Boby
Sam and Olivia are uh trying to rescue a
cat from the parking lot right now oh oh
a kitten under someone's car can we see
the phone out there someone take the
phone out there and record it I don't
think I don't want to show the outside
good call good call live setting showing
the license plates
laughs
yeah dude cam you got 10 followers for
one dollar I would put unlimited spend
button on Teddy fresh if I could get
that right that's 10 cents per follower
that's insane that's a good that's a
good amount wow dude that's like Godly
are you kidding it's insane dude yeah
that's Godly
but I think it must have just tapped
into like the H3 audience and got like
probably crazy conversion rate
uh dubric scuff new fan uh pizza place
getting
vandalized I didn't even know
I guess I have been following it a
little bit but it's opening dobrik now
we were talking about this off the air
yesterday Del brick is a great name but
now that people hate him it's a horrible
name like it's such a risk to put your
name in The Brand because if people turn
on you that brand is dead yeah
but like you think like Kendra but I
guess I mean I can live without her like
Papa John's kept the name that's true
oh wow that is a weird one it is weird
but they did it that's interesting yeah
so dobricks he has no pizza experience
I'm not sure about this whole thing it's
like the guy's a huge piece of [ __ ] but
I got the pizza the pizza looks bomb as
[ __ ] oh you we can I want to see what
the actual pie looks like yeah the logo
is linked in the website
okay here you hate the logo yeah his
little character
here let's take a look apparently David
is like he stopped posting on YouTube
but he's like all up in Snapchat and
I've seen I know people that are have
like Snapchat agreements and the revenue
they make on there is like insane really
insane like way more than YouTube
crazy so he must be making a grip I
don't know why I mean I'm not on
Snapchat at all I think I opened up a
video Once dude and there's a mid-roll
like every 10 seconds is that right yeah
well there you go saturation is [ __ ]
nuts but is anyone actually using
SnapChat like what I didn't think so but
apparently they are there's a lot of
people there some people using stuff I
think those people are still on it
they're just used to it because it was
around before like Instagram stories and
every other platform doing it so true I
only use Instagram to flirt with a young
young boys other than that I'm not I
don't watch the content or anything in
my Snapchat
what I say you said Instagram yeah I
meant Snapchat
what you doing on Instagram yeah I said
what you doing on Instagram
oh the same thing frankly
two years ago okay
yeah thank you so here it is
dobrex Pizza
there's a point to this by the way over
this kind of I don't know if it's a
funny twist but it is a twist
hey guys this is crazy I got a new pizza
place
dude this is insane oh it's so crazy I
can't believe this
this is insane whoa the cruise you broke
the [ __ ] Gilbert's Pizza
whoa look at them reacting oh crazy
freaking loud dude
oh that's it doesn't throw your hand
back like him too
Flash
every Pizza you get a coin
oh God nft
actually physical can I play it it's a
shop every time you order a full Pizza
you get a dobrix token and there's two
uses to the Token you can either take it
right here around to our side window
where you get a free scoop of ice cream
when you trade this in or use it for the
restroom it's the only way in
or you can come in here
now that's a Vibe your coin some places
do that
right here where it's this pizza party
you just drop it in and then this button
lights up
I hate this so much Taylor Lautner is a
genius I hate it it's so annoying to be
in there can you imagine yeah
can you imagine dude it's got to be so
annoying inside of there
uh Sam was saying she likes the pizza
box though
looks expensive that piece is gonna be
so expensive a bit
oh you're gonna scan the QR code inside
the pizza box lid
here's the website so Zach was saying
the pizza looks good actually oh
this is dobrics what is this why am I
getting a warning
hackers might be trying to steal your
information at dobricks.com
password message credit cards David
dobrik
what is happening
should I go it says unsafe
if it says that maybe not what's the
domain delbricks.com
uh I still try to bypass and it says 403
Forbidden I tested it this morning it
worked yo his website makes me [ __ ] if
you can't even bypass it
is that his did it get hacked or some
[ __ ] no I'm gonna try and mobile now
possibly
what yeah it says forbidden it won't
even let oh yeah cloudflare Dave needs
getting ddosed yeah he got hacked his
website got [ __ ] that's crazy
wow dude when did this launch I think I
think he just announced it like a day or
two ago the restaurant's supposed to
open tomorrow
well can you find a picture of the pizza
regardless
let's see
um he's sending out
notifications
letting people know
hey
who are these people so we can be like
why are you promote this is so weird
that people would actually like
associate with him now see you guys
Sunday thank you for the goodies and
congrats Josie is that like Logan Paul's
ex-girlfriend or something yes yes so
she doesn't give a [ __ ]
obviously
that is okay all right there you go
all right let's see what this pizza
looks like bro what
those I don't know man what's on the
spoon what's on the spoon what the [ __ ]
is that honey
there's two different styles there's one
called Tavern and then there's I forgot
what it's called the other one nah dude
that doesn't look good oh no crust
that doesn't look good to me it's like a
thin crust I don't know about the this
one but the first one does look like
Chicago
Pizza Uno Pizza wait but why is he
putting honey on it go back to the first
one he's ever been in the pizza category
am I crazy or is he pouring honey on it
can we not talk about that I don't know
Spanish pouring honey on a pizza why is
this happening it's juice bro don't
knock it till you try it I guess
what am I crazy honey on a pepperoni
pizza
are you sure it's honey pepperoni pizza
drizzled with hot honey that's what it
says oh that's the description what I
mean you like sweet on your uh pizza and
maybe it's not that bad I'm intrigued by
Honey on pizza oh my God keep on the
chat saying don't sleep on honey on
Pizza well have you ever had honey on
cheese like in a in a cheese plate it
goes oh really good I've just never
heard of it I'm just yeah I've never
heard of it either I'm seeing a decent
amount of people in the chats and
they're into it you like this Sam
loved it it was so good there you go
maybe it's worth a shot
honey on Pizza it's so good really yeah
we just Ian and I just had it recently
it was awesome there's a very popular
like Middle Eastern dessert called knife
it which is like
it's my favorite place I could kind of
see the peel you know I haven't had a
pizza since I started this diet and
that's [ __ ] crazy I haven't had pizza
in like three months why'd you bring
that up a b I've had over four ounces in
the last 30 days like a nephew yeah hell
yeah let's show a picture
okay well dope well anyway the point
that I'm talking about about doe bricks
is that um honestly the picture is not
going to do it justice by the way we
gotta start doing influencer product
reviews I really want to get that going
guys and I'm talking about like doll
bricks Beast Burger yeah we've got a
whole list we're working on it okay
great great that's gonna be so much fun
I'm so excited for that
Teddy fresh of course which You're Gonna
Love you're forced to love that
this don't look right guys
like that much honey
how much honey put on it
it just seems a little over the top I
mean you're looking at like the
unhealthiest Square you can put it in
your body but also this is like the
commercial yeah exactly you gotta see
like real customer photo you know yeah
especially when it comes to Pizza like I
don't know this picture doesn't yeah
they put like WWE 40 on that [ __ ] you
know wait is this a dobric's ad
yeah dude I don't like their little
pepperonis there's just too much and
they're all curled up they look like
used condoms
like I just don't like pepper only like
that it ain't right
but okay what do I know
um
so here's why I'm talking about it
somebody vandalized it uh a day or last
night or the day before
where's the screenshot of that
because
I think it's actually linked it yeah all
right here
yeah so here is the original all right
I'm gonna show a keemstar tweet because
you guys
don't have a picture
and because I guess keemstar had a dub
take I'm not willing to give him credit
this joke writes itself but okay it's
still good he says David dobrik Pizzeria
was vandalized last night with the word
rapist dobric and Vlog Squad were
spotted covering it up not the first
time the blog squad has been seen
covering up
right
crickets in the room literally I I was I
no listen listen
all the information I hate to give it to
him but
that's a good tweet right there shout
out to uh Dan
scoring points with the big guy
so yeah Somebody went and tagged it up
you know it was pretty wild but
obviously are emotional about it and
what's really interesting to me is that
like okay if this happened
uh uh this is something I owned I would
probably call in a professional to do it
but I guess David and his crew show up
to cover it and we were kind of
speculating why we think it might be I
think it's until somebody shows up to
take care of it oh they're just covering
it they really don't want anybody seeing
that
yeah but
they kind of just drew more attention to
it now it's out now everyone's seen it
yeah but we thought they went and did
that because they didn't want someone to
come and yeah see it
that's wild
the chat is agreeing rare rare Keem w
so I was happy to hand it to him I was
trying to find out how people know for
sure this is the the Vlog Squad and it
seems like a lot of people that are
mentioning this just lead to keem's
tweet so but they just make it up that's
awesome
that's so awesome I mean here's a nice
car and people and young people yeah
it's not almost like it's not a stretch
of the man it is being covered instead
of like yeah painted or whatever you
would do
yeah it doesn't really matter who's
doing it I guess
but there you go David dobrik is I wanna
I wanna scroll interesting yeah I'm not
gonna it'll be like a a [ __ ] come
tribute
[Applause]
oh yeah
did you know that I'm the one that made
that
no you didn't I'm just kidding
just big twist what up guys
I know you didn't he's gonna remember
forever he's gonna report that dude
it's true unwanted
tension on me a [ __ ] baby and I
report everything Ethan what is
happening yeah I loved it it's a long
show we've been how long we've been
going uh three and a half hours and I
know you guys have to leave by five
which is in 10 minutes so but what about
Nikita Dragon I mean we ran out of time
I don't know
can we talk about it really fast I feel
like it deserves more than just like
rushing through it's like kind of a
heavy serious story
well all right well she got arrested she
went to prison and then the judge forced
her to be in the Men's prison is [ __ ]
crazy it's horrible it's it's really
[ __ ] up yeah and uh she's out now I
don't know if uh okay but but that's
basically it and there's well there's
some updates the prisons denying that
they held there hmm yeah but I saw in
the in the video she's like in prison in
a jumpsuit yeah it seems like clear
[ __ ] but uh like here's the video
that came out of her yeah I don't I
don't believe the police department but
they're they're just don't lie
isn't that illegal
um here's the video of her asking the
judge can you please put me in a women's
prison
and dude it's gotta be like scary and
dangerous that's really scary in a Men's
prison yeah it's so dangerous yeah it's
kind of the statistics around trans
women in male units is it's bad it's
pretty horrible that's horrible and I
you know it's kind of
um
intuitive right like you wouldn't want
to do that for their safety right is
they always they always protect people
in jail like if you're like a a child
molester or not I don't always but like
if you're if you're in danger to the
general public they'll do make efforts
to protect you
and yeah today yeah they do like if you
go in there they'll set you apart from
the general population if they yeah
because yeah and yet and yet when it
comes to her they're like nah you could
[ __ ] you're St you're [ __ ] that's
so messed up
so quiet
good morning man
it's just this quiet
what is this what am I watching why is
there four
probably representation yeah the state
attorney in the top right uh who's this
guy
um probably a previous
it's this person who's on the lineup
somebody else if you go to oh it's
somebody else okay yeah okay I get it
they're like going through the doctor
got it got it got it to be addressed if
you go to 6D if you just the condensed
version
okay thank you
thank you thank you that makes me so sad
just
well it is actually a serious story
because the the system needs to catch up
it's just [ __ ] up
tampons
um
yeah I'm
and I don't stop there but I just call
for accommodation for you you just need
a separate a separate area and you can
you can contact the bondsman and try and
get you out
I want to see a bonds the bondsman she's
like oh yeah if you wanna you gotta talk
to the I'm sure the judge could have
moved her like are you [ __ ] kidding I
mean of course the judge could have
moved there
Hey listen I don't make the rules around
here
deal with it
they put her sex as male
and they called her a bro on eye color
that's [ __ ] up
a bro seriously oh
that's really sad and [ __ ] up and I'm
just like yes I hate it I feel like the
the info Leak with the booking where it
says that they marked her down as male
that's enough evidence to be like okay
had she been
placed out of holding than she would
have been in a men's unit like she was
clearly in a men's holding cell right
duh obviously why are they even denying
it so stupid
like where is she she's in prison right
she's on Zoom she's talking to judge
where is she yeah exactly
[ __ ] the police forever
a cab [ __ ] it
for real dude I'm so sick of the [ __ ]
lying ass police
but yeah feel bad for her
and uh apparently she's going through
like uh I don't know a manic episode I I
don't know oh really but she it's the
reason she got arrested is she was
running around a pool in a hotel naked
or something I don't know she was
causing disturbance to walk around the
hotel pool and Lobby naked blasting loud
music from her room
after hotel security warned her
she was met by police it was reported
that Nikita threw an open bottle of
water at the officers which of course
they took as a threat of Life against
them Yo she's supposed one owner taser
Yoshi spots water on me
shoot to kill
and then charged with felony assault
I just like dude if she's clearly on a
manic episode like this is so dumb well
she got lucky they usually kill people
who are on manic episodes
I can't honestly stories about this kind
of stuff makes me so sad I really can't
even handle it
yeah the policing system here is
probably the most [ __ ] up thing going
on in our country I mean one of them for
sure it's disgusting every time dude and
it's like every [ __ ] day practically
you see a video on Reddit of some sick
[ __ ] sadistic police officer
who's just destroying someone's life for
no goddamn reason
she was only set at a 2 000 Bond so I'm
sure that was easy to head for her I
mean she has money as far as I'm aware
actually when they ask her that she says
that she has to check
shouldn't have two thousand
I don't know
I thought she was a bowler didn't she
have like a Ferrari and [ __ ]
and she sold all the makeup she got that
makeup dollar
yeah she has Brands and stuff
didn't I know if she had it available at
the moment yeah she's unwell mentally
yeah like if you're like
in psychosis you can't figure that out
or maybe if she's in psychosis somebody
is taking her access away you know like
maybe she doesn't actually have access I
don't know I don't know anything about
you know the situation yeah that the
police Miami-Dade
Florida plus police even worse
Corrections and Rehabilitation
department is committed to protecting
the rights of transgender community and
all lgbtq people the statement said the
police have have procedures in place for
the appropriate intake housing and
medical needs of transgender inmates and
we are committed to ensuring that all
inmates in our custody including
transgender people are treated
appropriately through our intake
classification and place placement
process are you going to talk about what
happened or are you just gonna you know
it's like you're not even addressing
what happened
they're like it's like that one letter
about slavery that we just read last
time
slavery we have officially uh we are
against slavery
she got out on Wednesday
so
there it is
we got to do better folks
but she got out I don't think anything
happened to her that I heard and uh
there it is she should have called PMP
frankly yeah p p would have set that
judge straight let's go exactly hit her
with one of those case closed
my client my beautiful client here was
uh running around the hotel naked and
it's like in a psych it's like a state
of psychosis police approached her she
threw water in their face tried to grab
their taser uh took a [ __ ] on the grass
I don't know I'm not this didn't happen
I'm just trying to let's go
and uh she actually stabbed one of the
police and uh well once I talked to the
D.A we were able to get that down to
misdemeanor
um
so she's all good now yeah just a 25
fine
PNP forever all right that's it it's
five yo we've been going way too [ __ ]
long we did it we did all of it thank
you Olivia thank you Olivia thank you
thank you thank you to everyone
uh got glammed out and looks is
fantastic Elis doppelganger Sally and
huckstep have you guys know who that is
but I gotta Google this real fast
let's see
huh
I don't see it do you I don't see it at
all
oh I mean the eyes a little bit and the
lips there's something there at that at
that angle a little bit but I don't know
when you see her face on I don't see the
results at all I think it's racist
what are you trying to say
yeah I don't see anything
I guess I don't know
what did she do she's a murderer well
that's oh thank you oh she's the sex
worker turned hero oh who exposed
Australia's dirtiest cup okay okay I'll
take that Queen
Ing we gotta get Sally Ann on the show
there it is thank you guys all right
have a great weekend uh we'll be back on
Monday as always so next week we do have
Howie right
yeah next uh Wednesday
and then guess who's coming in on Friday
Bradley yeah Bradley Martin those are
those are gonna be fun I'm looking
forward to both of those me too yeah
we're gonna have a lot of fun stuff for
both of those episodes I think Bradley
will probably be down for a makeup
tutorial too what's going on with your
makeup go round too crazy here we have
PewDiePie on Monday too right PewDiePie
yeah oh yeah PewDiePie's coming on it's
gonna be here in person
he'll be here in the studio
I'm taking these off actually really
easy that's not real by the way for any
new listeners
that's an old meme what do you mean
yeah we told a joke for like a year that
people that PewDiePie was coming on the
next episode people are so confused for
so longer than they realize he ain't
coming
okay well guys have a great weekend like
I said uh peace and love peace and love
see you guys on Monday
thanks for watching this super [ __ ]
long episode
mm-hmm let's end on a pride minute
seriously that's a whole lot
a minute I'll go through a prime minute
for Nikita yeah yeah okay let's do it
well you're the one hurrying me up for a
minute now we're gonna take a minute you
know that then I gotta get into my
sermon okay yeah no you know we'll all
be thinking it pride moment right now we
can have we can have it on Monday we'll
have it right back yeah
all right guys love y'all I gotta go
play some God of War
kabish
double salute
for veterans one for the veterans one
for the
um civilians for the cities yeah
yeah when do we do that
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]